Five four,
three,
two,
one.
Donny Vincent,
what's going on?
How are you buddy?
Good.
I look good.
Very excited that you didn't know about
floating at all.
He didn't know about float tanks even
remotely until you came here.
Yeah.
And it's wicked looking.
It's fun,
man.
If you've got time after the show,
you can float.
If you want to do it,
I might have to do it just to say that
I've done it.
But yeah,
I,
I didn't know the science behind it
other than obviously floating right.
Would be,
you know,
just feels good just to meditate and
just to sit there in a quiet,
like,
you know,
when you,
when you're a little kid and you go on a
swimming pool or something,
you put your ears just under the water
and you get that kind of,
yeah.
When everything's just peaceful and you
can just sit there and you can't hear
your mother or you can't hear your
girlfriend or whatever and it's just
quiet.
I assume.
It's a lot like that.
It's very telling me,
he said to women,
you didn't say your dad,
you didn't see your grandpa.
My Dad never talked to me.
And maybe that's a whole nother subject.
That's another part of the problem
probably.
But uh,
yeah,
I am trying to get floating spread
across where like this is the best way
for people to relax.
It does nothing like it because first of
all physically you're relaxed because
the water has so much epson salts in it
and you know,
it's just really good for your muscles.
It's good for sore,
you know,
anything.
Sore muscles overworked.
It's great for that.
But it's also great in the environment
where you,
you were in that tank with total
darkness,
total silence.
It's pitch black in there.
You close the door,
you don't see a ray of light and then
your ears are underwater.
And then I have to get some earplugs for
guests.
I don't mind having the,
the,
the salt in my ears,
but some people get a little weirded out
by the salt in there.
Do we have as women that,
yeah.
Did I buy,
I bought a big thing of it.
I did.
My memory's fucked up dude.
What's wrong with me?
Um,
about all giant jug of it.
Right?
But,
uh,
the other thing is that it just gives
you a lone time in a way that you don't
ever get when you're floating in there.
You're not thinking about your body,
you know,
thinking about anything.
You're just,
you're just floating and then it's just
very peaceful,
just a little bit.
What makes you,
you,
you have a real moment to consider
things.
I've had made some of my best decisions
in that thing and I don't think,
I mean obviously we all know the rat
race right now.
None of us.
I mean it's,
it's why I go to the mountains.
It's the same thing.
Like they're just sitting there and
peace in my mind has been doing this for
years where,
um,
early on in and when I would,
when I'm going in the Arctic,
or early on when I'd go into the
mountains or something like that,
everything was frantic.
Like I had to do things really quickly.
I wanted to cover a lot of ground.
I wanted to,
everything,
packing,
moving,
everything was so frantic.
And then when I started realizing that
if I would just stop and slow down and
look at the very tiniest details around
me,
no matter where I was or who I was with,
then I started having a great
appreciation of my presence.
So I'm sure something like that is just
because of the darkness and because of
the floating,
it's just hyper extended into that
presence of you can trick yourself into
thinking that nothing else is going on
in your life.
Yeah,
no,
I agree with you.
I think that we take this attitude that
we have in the city when you're dealing
with traffic and massive amounts of
people and you sort of have that same
momentum when you go into the mountains
and if you do do that,
you're not going to appreciate it the
same way.
Yeah,
for sure.
Look around.
Yeah,
I did that for a few years.
I would go,
I thought I had to accomplish something.
So I'd go to site a and hunt there then
and I tried to,
as horrible as the sentences to say,
I tried to kill as fast as I could so I
could get out of there and go to site B
and sight see.
And then I started realizing,
I actually had a friend of mine,
he's like,
man,
I think you're,
I think you're hunting too much.
I think this is going to catch up with
you and you're going to,
the experience is going to start to
degrade for you.
But it was,
it was almost like I was trying to
accomplish really fast goals and when I
started slowing that down and saying,
hey,
I don't want to go to the Arctic for
seven days and try to knock all of these
things off my list in seven days.
I want to go to the Arctic for 30 days
and now let the Arctic come to me.
Let Let.
Now I just want to sit still and be
quiet and not,
not chase the Arctic down,
but I want it just now.
I want it to come to me.
Well I think people for the La people
who don't have any experience in the
outdoors and certainly people who don't
hunt don't understand it and their
version of it they're getting either
from movies were hunters are always
portrayed as villains or they're getting
it from these outdoor TV shows,
which I don't think a good do a good job
of representing what it actually is.
Even the really good ones like Rinella
show,
which I think is the best show out
there,
it's still 22 minutes with commercials
and I just don't think that you get a
real sense of what it's like what I
think you did.
That's really interesting and one of the
reasons why I wanted to have you on.
As you're doing films,
like you're doing an hour long film
about a hunt and in that you really get
an understanding of the environment.
You take great shots or whoever your
camera man is great shots of being a
fireman and closeups on leaves floating
down a river and you just get,
you get a real sense of it,
which is missing.
And it's,
it's still,
you're still getting a blink of Oh,
you know,
multiple weeks in the wilderness.
Yup.
But you at least,
you get a feel like,
oh,
this is something very different than
what's being portrayed.
This is like this intense,
almost spiritual experience in this very
bizarre environment that surrounds
civilization.
And we think of it,
you know,
in these weird terms.
But when you're out there in it,
it's very difficult to capture what
that's like.
And I think you've done an amazing job
at doing that.
And here's,
Jamie's put some of your stuff up online
here.
We get a chance to see it.
But,
and I,
and I appreciate that it's um,
hunting.
It drives me nuts.
Go ahead.
No,
no,
I'm just,
I'm just going to say,
I mean,
whoever's doing your editing,
kyle,
he's fantastic.
Yeah,
he's really talented.
He does a really,
really good job of,
of just picking good shots.
And just the overall experience is
relayed very well.
Like you get a chance to see like,
oh,
this,
this is an adventure.
This isn't just as simple as,
you know,
someone's going out there trying to fill
a freezer with wild game meat.
No,
you're,
you're on an adventure.
And then the wild game meat is a part of
it.
Yeah.
It's all apps.
A lot of shit going on.
And this was,
this piece right here was specifically
don for Nat Geo because they have,
um,
the National Geographic Society,
which is the magazine.
And then they have national geographic,
which is the TV show.
And so they wanted to do,
they hit me up for a bunch of TV shows.
They wanted me to come and find bigfoot.
They wanted me to,
I,
yeah,
they call the fuck are,
they called me for everything.
They would call me and say,
ah,
we're,
where are you right now?
Where are,
where's your cabin?
And I'd say,
I don't have a cabin.
And they say,
well,
our,
I'm surely you're skinning a beaver out
right now.
I said,
no,
no.
I live in Wisconsin.
Just taught in Minneapolis and I'm
walking my labrador down the street in
shorts and,
and um,
and so they said,
well,
they,
they really want to do a TV show.
And they wanted it to encapsulate
hunting to some degree.
But the society,
the magazine was against hunting.
The TV show would allow it.
So they wanted me to do a no bullshit a
sermon if you will download looking down
the barrel of the camera and just said,
this isn't going to go public.
This,
this doesn't have to be pretty,
it's not going to be edited well,
but just please tell us why you hunt.
W try to explain it so that we can bring
it to our producers and saying like,
this is why he hunts.
And so I did this,
had my little temper tantrum there.
And um,
and in doing it realized like,
it made me really question,
you know,
I'd say,
okay,
so you want to know why I hunt?
And then it made me take a step back and
say,
man,
for the love of God,
I really don't even know.
I don't know why I hunt,
but I can explain some of the areas.
It doesn't explain why I'm a hunter.
It doesn't explain exactly why a hunt,
but I can tell you I love the adventure.
I can tell you I love the really clean
protein that I get for me and my family.
I can tell you that our ancestry
unequivocally comes from 100% groups of
hunters and gatherers that's around the
world.
I can tell you all of these points.
I can tell you that I love seeing
antlers of all sizes and and the hides,
and I can tell you I love watching
grizzly bears eat blueberries and
watching salmon come up a river to
spawn.
I can tell you all of these things,
but I don't know if all of those things
make me a hunter or if I'm just
experiencing all those things because I
am a hunter.
It's just very difficult to articulate.
It's very difficult to articulate how
much you love something,
yet you're willing to engage it in such
a heavy way,
such a violent way that you're willing
to step in,
kill it,
cut up,
get your hands
bloody.
Because really,
that's what it is.
We love it so much that we're willing to
expose ourselves to the elements,
put ourselves in these places,
let the air or the bullet go watch an
animal die,
which is never a never an interesting
thing to watch.
I say interesting,
but it's just not a pleasurable thing to
watch.
But this is how we engage as hunters
into these environments.
And so I was trying to convey that to
nat geo and a seven minute piece.
And Kyle,
um,
after he put it together,
he's like,
I think we should release this.
And I said,
hell no.
Hell No.
I talk about Peta in it.
I talk about being a vegetarian in it,
which I'm not against vegetarianism.
I'm pete as a joke.
But,
um,
but he insisted.
So he finally won the argument.
And you know,
well,
[inaudible],
you know,
the idea behind ethical treatment of
animals is amazing.
Of course.
I mean you,
like you were saying you have a
labrador.
The idea that hunters hate animals too
is also a very confusing thing.
This is ponders love animals.
You know,
there's a lot of hunters that have dogs
and cats.
Yeah.
But ethical treatment of animals is,
is imperative.
It's very important.
I mean we are,
if we are really the stewards of nature,
if we were really the top of the food
chain and we most certainly are we and
we're conscious and we have a
conscience,
we absolutely should be ethical in our
treatment of animals and take care of
them and be kind to them.
Which the problem with Peta is that's
not really what they're about.
They're the Animal Liberation
Organization.
That's what they really are,
what they're about.
They don't want any animals to be pets.
They don't want people to have pets.
Like this is,
I mean this sounds radical,
but it's absolutely true.
In fact,
Peta euthanizes thousands of pets a
year,
they kill pets and they killed them
quickly.
They don't keep him alive very long.
And the idea being is that for the
critics,
the,
the idea has been bandied about is they
don't want these animals to live and
breed and stay pets.
They want animals to only be wild,
and that's fine,
but there's thousands and thousands of
years of domesticated animals,
and if you want to let those animals
loose,
it have them wild.
You have a whole another series of
problems.
Unless you want to kill all the golden
retrievers and all the Chihuahuas.
Not that they're not going to survive in
the wild.
So like,
yeah,
we've perpetuated pass that a long time
ago.
Yeah.
They're not wild animals.
They're just not.
No.
Yeah.
Like a,
like a little fat kids.
Not a wild animal.
Either.
You leave him in the woods,
he's going to die just as quickly as
your fucking Chihuahua.
He's going to be food.
Yeah.
They're not going to make it.
Yes.
This is not,
you know,
so there's a,
there's a weird ideology that they're
attached to that is,
it's,
it's not tenable.
It's not,
no,
you can't argue it.
You know,
the idea of ethical treatment of
animals,
I'm 100% with that.
I fucking hate the whole idea of captive
orkis.
That to me is one of the big rows that
freaks me the fuck out.
That we can take these alien creatures
that are essentially as smart as us
probably and put them in swimming pools
and justify it.
And that the only time they've ever
killed people in recorded history has
been in those swimming pools.
They don't kill people in the wild.
They kill everything else.
They kill whales,
they killed dolphins,
they kill sharks.
They don't fuck with people.
In fact,
there's been instances where they've
saved people and yet we've decided to
put those.
So me and Peter are on the hundred
percent the same page as that.
And Pete has retweeted a bunch of shit
that I've put up before,
which is really weird.
They retweeted a bunch of shit that I've
put up about,
you know,
about,
uh,
orcas.
And when I've done that,
people like,
uh,
you know,
he hunts,
right?
And then,
then it gets,
you know,
radio silence,
they don't want to comment on that.
They just want to support my hate for,
you know,
Orca.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I had,
um,
one of the most,
I've had some,
I've been fortunate to have remarkable
engagements with wildlife in my life,
but two years ago in NBC,
I had one with a killer whale and it
was,
it was wicked.
And to this day I regret not making the
decision I'm about to tell you about,
but we had been,
um,
I'd been bear hunting on the coast and
we were in a boat cruising back to the
harbor and we found two pods of killer
whales,
uh,
three big bowls and a bunch of cows that
were hunting.
And,
uh,
we kept as they would come up,
they were chasing salmon and as they
would come up,
we've just get closer just to film them
or even just to see them and then they'd
go down.
And so,
I don't know if it was just happenstance
of where we were,
but we came up and we were just kind of
waiting for the whole pod to come up and
all of a sudden,
just 50 feet from the boat.
Here comes the huge dorsal fin of this
bowl,
comes right at our boat,
bumps into our boat.
I'm standing on the,
in the crow's nest,
essentially I'm on the roof of the boat
looking at the same,
he comes up,
bumps into our boat and he just glides
his left side all along the boat.
So his left pectoral fin is probably
under our gunnel,
if you will,
or under our hall.
And so he's just dragging his finn and
he rotates on his side,
dragging his dorsal fin along our side
exhales covering,
I'm our director of photography Williams
face in his spray.
And as he's doing this,
he goes,
he hugs the bowel of our boat and he
never ever breaks eye contact with me.
He's staring at me out of his left eye,
literally rolling his eye over and he
just cruises all the way around the
boat.
And,
uh,
I wanted to dive in and I just wasn't
sure.
Like I didn't want to be one of these,
you got to die.
I didn't want to be the first guy to
die.
And I also didn't want to have like some
sort of shallow water blackout because
the water was so cold.
So I didn't want to dive in and have all
of a sudden,
like I didn't know how my body would
react cause I hadn't been in the water
yet.
And so,
um,
and then also I was like,
I,
you know,
I'd watched black fish or whatever that
film is really killed a bunch of folks
that you know,
in,
in seaworld and NBC
and saw.
I was just like,
well what if you know,
there's gotta be at first,
you know,
wolves never killed anyone any either.
And then,
you know,
some young lady when jogging and
[inaudible] son of a bitch,
we have number one.
Well,
there's a long history of killing people
though in the past.
I'm just saying,
you know,
like,
in recorded time,
but it was still,
it was,
it was a,
and he maintained eye contact turned and
then just continued on with the hunt.
But it was the only film all this,
yeah.
Well you filmed as much as we could
because it happened really fast.
But yeah,
it was wicked.
Absolutely wicked.
I mean,
literally his,
you know,
his dorsal fins probably 10 feet tall
and it is just,
you know,
when you drag something against another
on in an object with force,
you know,
it's finished.
Just,
you know,
he was just very engaged with the boat
as a doorstop.
Oh really?
That tall?
Yeah.
It's like,
it's gotta be eight,
nine,
10 feet.
That's fucking crazy.
I guess.
It makes sense.
They're so big.
Fuck man.
I've never seen one in the wafs seen
dolphins in the wall and I've seen
whales in the wild.
I've never seen an Orca.
Yeah.
There,
I mean wicked animals.
We don't even,
we can't even comprehend what that
animal,
that if Orca is weren't real and big
foot was real,
we wouldn't give a shit about big foot,
big foot who'd be in the zoo right next
to the fucking orangutans.
You know,
we'd be like,
look at the big monkey stupid monkey,
you know?
Yeah.
But orcas,
I mean they speak in a language that we
can't decipher.
We don't know what they're saying,
but we know that they have dialects.
We know that they stay in these pods for
life.
They,
they,
they have this family organization and
they all stay in their clan there.
They're fucking incredible.
And you've seen,
you've seen black fish obviously.
Oh yeah.
I so much as I could watch,
I could watch the whole thing and I get
angry.
I get,
I get furious that this is a,
a giant business,
that they take these things and they buy
them from other organizations.
And I've had,
you know,
I just,
I've had real problems with it for a
long time and I'm,
I felt my friend Phil Demars,
he was a,
a a trainer at marine land and he's been
on the podcast many,
many times and he's involved in these
constant lawsuits with Bahrain land.
Um,
he was a walrus trainer and he also
trained killer whales and you know,
he's given us some real insight into the
horrors of what it's like in marine land
and even in seaworld and what they're
doing and how they,
how they get these orchids and,
and how they're treated and how bad it
is for them to be trapped in these
environments and how their dorsal fins
go limp because they never have to deal
with current.
So the atrophy,
that whole thing is sick.
It's sick.
Do they still have them now and killer
whales at sea world now?
Yes.
Yeah,
they still have them.
they can't,
they can't buy new ones apparently or
something like that.
There's someone here.
Fantastic.
Yeah,
that's the whole thing.
They can't,
I think they could still breed them
though.
I mean,
the whole thing is fucked up,
man.
It's,
it's just like slavery.
If like we had aliens as slaves,
we just couldn't,
were like,
what are you saying?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know what you're saying,
dude.
Get in the pool.
If you want to fish in the fucking pool.
I mean,
that's basically what's going on.
It's gross.
Yeah.
It's,
it's sick.
It's twisted.
Yeah.
You know,
and I just,
uh,
so that's where me and peed were,
we're on the same page.
Yeah.
I think anyone,
honestly,
uh,
treating anything with ethics,
right.
Particularly animals,
of course a hunters are animal lovers.
You know,
we rescue dogs,
we rescue cats.
We,
it's,
it absolutely goes without saying,
which is where the contention comes
from.
That's where the questions come from.
That's,
I,
I get,
I get as many letters from non hunters
and from,
you know,
people that think that they're against
hunting or have,
um,
maybe damning questions than I do from a
hunters themselves.
You know,
I get,
I get letters from Hunter's,
I'd say you're a bad ass or you really
inspire me or you,
you know,
I'm,
I'm really happy that I can have my kids
watch your films.
Like I don't let them watch a hunting
tv,
but when we sit down and they want to
see something,
they want to ingest something that has
hunting and you know,
we'll watch your films.
And so I think that's really cool.
But I get a lot of questions from non
hunters and then people that have some
contention with it.
Well I think there's a lot of people out
there that are curious.
I mean 90 depending on who you asked,
95 or 90% 97% of the population eats
meat and the percentage that actually
killed that meet themselves is
incredibly small.
It's probably like a 1% you know what I
mean?
I don't know what it is.
It might be a little bit harder than
that,
but it's no more than five.
And there's a lot of people that are
just on the fence and they're there.
They're just sitting there going,
well,
I eat it but I don't kill myself.
But I,
I somehow or another were angry that
someone's doing it themselves.
Like my,
before I ever thought about hunting,
my thoughts about hunters were that they
were cruel people that like to kill
animals.
Why would you kill animals?
It's not necessary.
You can buy meat from a store.
This is the very shallow thinking that I
had,
you know,
decades ago.
Then,
you know,
as I started getting older and really
considering what I do with my body and
what kind of food I put in,
and then the internet was a big one
because the internet came along and I
started watching those videos that a lot
of them that Peter puts up of factory
farming,
oh and I'm terrible.
It's horrible.
It's not just terrible.
It's like,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's like this is,
this is like human beings at their very
worst that we've treated these things as
like the the most,
I mean not just as a commodity,
but we've ignored their feelings and
their thoughts and their,
the fact that they have instincts and
needs.
And that we've stuffed them into these
tiny little cages.
It's a sickness.
Then you see the cruel,
inhumane treatment that some of the
people that work there,
you know,
and people that work in farms will tell
you,
look,
this is very rare and these are isolated
instances and this is terrible.
That's well and good.
But there's also ag gag laws that
prevent people from filming agricultural
gag laws that prevent people from
filming on these factory farms because
they don't want people to know how
horrific those conditions are.
So it's,
there's some truth to it.
I mean,
maybe they're isolated instances.
Maybe it's a small percentage of the
farms that do treat their animals like
that.
But it's significant enough that they're
worried about the impact on the economy
to the point where they're passing laws
that keep people from filming and
showing people what it's like in these
places.
And you can even just show people
without any abuse,
just show what's going on.
Just even a still photo of how they're
living and you're not going to want to
consume the food.
And these and the people that they think
that these animals were raised this way
right there.
Their cows,
their bovines,
they're big dumb animals.
They were bred for this.
Who Cares?
They have no idea what's going on until
that spike hits him or they get
electrocuted or they get their throats
slit.
But if you have anywhere with hall at
all,
if you have any,
being any soul at all,
and maybe this is the wrong
idealization or the wrong picture and
building my head,
but if you,
if you make yourself the cow just for a
second,
if you remove yourself just for a
freaking second and just say like is,
is this how I would want to be treated?
Is this how I would want to live?
Is this how I would want to die?
Then you start to ask yourself some
pretty big questions that are relatively
easy to answer and we have a lot of
people on the earth right now and it's
going to continue until something big
happens.
But if you,
if,
if you can remove yourself from your own
ego and from your own comfort and try to
visualize at all what these other
animals are going through,
even animals you're hunting,
um,
it's gonna make you better and more
cognizant of being ethical and treating
everything with absolute care even in
killing it.
Yeah.
I mean,
contradictions there though,
right?
With hunting because like if you really
care about the animal,
why would you kill it?
Right.
That's,
yeah.
That's the big question.
Yeah.
So hardest thing to wrap your head
around.
Yeah.
If you're not,
if you're not in doing our wilderness
is,
it's,
it's absolutely wild.
I mean,
public lands in particular,
they're very there.
It's absolutely wild.
But it's also a very weird,
because a lot of the funding for that
wildlife comes from people that buy
hunting tags and hunting equipment in
order to kill those animals.
So the way those animals are sustained
and the way the wildlife's are protected
in the way that the wardens and game
rangers are paid is a lot of it is
through the hunters who want to go out
and kill the animals that live on it.
So it's like a lot of people like,
well Keith,
this is wild sorta,
but it's also,
I mean sword a sword.
It's protected by people that want to go
in that water.
I mean engage it.
Yeah,
not,
I mean we're reducing it to a single
variable.
So you want to protect these Lx,
you can go in there and kill an elk.
No,
I want to protect these.
First of all,
I want to protect the habitat so these l
can thrive and then in certain instances
in and remove
a few animals or in certain instances,
like if you're in Alaska or something
like that and hunting a stable Caribou
herd,
you can go in and remove,
you know,
not everything is based off of sole
management,
right?
As animals encroach where people are,
we need to cut their numbers down
because humans have taken up so much
land.
But,
um,
there are other populations that are
trending in relative harmony.
If they have big,
huge scales of land and we're not
drilling for oil or whatever,
who already can go and remove a few a
few animals in their Predator and prey
scenario and it works just fine for the
herd.
It works just fine for the population.
And actually,
um,
in a very small way helps the population
by removing certain animals for an age
class or a sex class,
things like that.
But,
um,
that's the difficulty is we're,
we're preserving the habitat so that we
can go in and engage in the wild.
Right.
I mean,
I think also a lot of people,
they think you buy your gun,
you buy your bow,
you buy your tag,
you go to Utah,
you leave with an elk.
Well,
that is how it works for like 15% of the
people,
if that,
but there's a whole contingent of 80% or
90% of people that buy their bowl by
their gun,
by their pickup truck,
get their hotel room,
get their tent hike 20 miles into the
wilderness,
strike out,
listened to a lot of quiet,
look around,
hike out,
get back in their truck,
drive home,
send me an email saying,
where is it that you find elk around
September 15th in Utah.
And so there's instill those people are
engaging in still,
you know,
and there's all different wides.
There's,
you know,
there's fly fishermen in El counters
and,
and there's people that just want to
take photos and so everyone has their
different engagement.
But that's really what it's about.
And we have what we're trending towards
8 billion people on the face of the
earth.
So
large scale agriculture and farming and
in animal agriculture as well has
created this environment where people
can thrive in these cities where they're
not growing any food.
I mean California,
where we're at right now,
it's one of the weirdest places on the
planet earth.
There's 20 million people.
No one's growing anything.
But we'd,
I mean,
look around here,
it's just a fucking,
there's no farms out here,
man.
No,
it's farms.
It's,
it's,
it's completely,
we're in the people that are,
a lot of these people that are writing a
lot of these people that are against
this.
They're so hypocritical.
They're eating cheeseburgers while the
types and how hypocritical.
Very strange.
But I've been that person.
I've been that meat eating person who
thought that that hunters recording,
I've been that person.
I get it.
I know where they're coming from.
And,
and I've considered vegetarianism and V
and when I was fighting,
I was a Vegan or a vegetarian rather
for,
I guess I was probably considered Vegan.
I don't think I was eating any cheese
and I wasn't drinking any milk.
But I did that for like six months.
It didn't,
it just didn't agree with me,
you know?
I mean maybe I didn't do it right and I
never did it again.
But I was doing it to try to lose weight
as what else.
I was also not eating enough.
I was,
it was,
there was a lot going on there cause I
was trying to fight it,
a low weight class.
But um,
a lot of people do it and they do it
well and it works for them,
but they have to understand even that's
not clean man,
large scale agriculture in terms of
farming,
that shit,
it kills a lot of animals and it
displaces a lot of wildlife.
You're never supposed to have a thousand
acres of soybeans or a thousand acres of
corn or a thousand acres of fucking
wheat or anything,
anything.
All that shit is fake.
All that shit is something someone's put
there.
And when they're using pesticides that
killing things and when they're using
those combines,
they are grinding up bunnies and fucking
rats and mice and killing countless
bugs.
So the idea that you're getting away
without killing any sentient life,
it's bullshit.
And even look at the,
so the corridor of the Mississippi
River,
right used to be solid wetlands and our
wetlands is how we recycle water.
It's how we,
that stinky biomass that you smell,
that that's clean water being made,
that's detritus materially being,
being processed.
Mississippi River used to be completely
lined with these wetlands.
Farmers have one in [inaudible] and
obviously it's not the farmer's fault.
This is just as soon as we started
agriculture,
1314 15,000 years ago,
the stopwatch was hit.
We went one direction.
You cannot go away.
We were hunters and gatherers.
We could only raise so many children.
We had to move with the food.
We had to move away from our excrement.
We had to keep a small population.
But the second we figured out how to
grow corn and rice and stay in one place
and raise more than one child,
and now we're close to our excrement.
Literally the stopwatch to something
that is going to be a fantastic event
has started.
I don't know if I'm going to see it.
I don't know if you're going to see it,
but something wicked is coming.
And,
and,
and there's no other way to look around.
And there's there,
there's anyway,
something big as overpopulation,
overpopulation,
something will happen.
You know,
human beings are animals.
We have awesome thumbs,
we have great brains,
but we are nothing.
There's nothing amazing about us.
We can fly to the moon,
we can do all this great stuff.
By the way,
I loved your discussion with your flat
Arthur Guy.
That was freaking amazing.
And the other guy that thinks if you eat
the perfect amount of food,
you won't Poop or pee.
That's silly.
Fuck.
California remains the leading us date
for cash farm receipts.
Biggest state with,
oh yeah,
that's,
yeah,
but that's outside of La.
If you go outside.
Yeah,
we're just talking about La,
California as a lot of farms.
In fact,
if you drive from La and you go to
Fresno,
like when we were working to Fresno,
it was fucking nothing but farms like
all the way up to San Francisco.
Nothing but farms.
It's a lot of almond farming,
tomatoes,
Avocados.
But you look at,
so we've gotten rid of our wetlands and
now where are our soils are saw dust.
There's nothing in them anymore.
So we pump in the nitrogen we pump in.
The phosphate still reigns to cause a
lot of people don't understand that you,
when you use,
when you grow vegetables on a plot of
land over and over and over again,
you deplete
the soil of all the minerals.
Yeah.
Because you're not letting anything die
there,
right.
You are pulling from the earth,
you're harvesting the plant,
nothing is dying.
Nothing is returning back to the earth.
And so your er,
so then the next year you don't have
that detritus material creating a,
all the goodies and the soils,
the bugs,
the,
the microbes.
You don't have these funguses,
you don't have these symbiotic
relationships that are working with all
of these insects and microbes diamond,
so that,
that create your soil to be a living
system.
We've as,
as we push all that into the plant and
we harvest it and we just keep doing
that repeatedly.
Well,
there's less and less of this biomass in
the soil.
So we have to then go in and fertilize
with nitrogen and phosphorous to give
our plants nitrogen fixation,
things like this to grow these plants.
Then we harvest them.
Then rains come.
There's a Rojan all of the soil.
So we lose some of our top soils,
which brings us down to even more other
different levels of soils that need even
more chemicals brought into them so they
can actually grow something.
But all these soils that are heavily
laden with,
with nitrogen fosters porn in the
Mississippi River.
And people know about this.
I'm not saying anything that isn't,
um,
it hasn't been extremely well documented
and pushes down to the Gulf of Mexico.
The sunlight hits it.
All of this,
uh,
Al Algal blooms happen.
All this allergy hits this nitrogen and
phosphorous.
It grows.
It just like it grows a corn stock,
the sunlight hits it.
It,
they have these huge blooms that needs
oxygen to function.
So it creates these huge hip oxic zones,
right?
You've heard these things called dead
zones.
Fish can't live in them.
And so anyone that's hangs their hat on
being a vegetarian or,
and I know there's reasons for being a
vegetarian.
I know there's people that refuse to
there.
They don't want to kill the animal
themselves.
Um,
and,
um,
and they're not going to buy from a
factory farm.
I probably have more in common with
vegetarian people that,
that don't want to kill their own
animals and,
and,
um,
aren't willing to eat factory grown food
that than I have with some of my,
uh,
hunters.
Then with other hunters,
you're saying it seems,
and um,
and I,
and I also,
um,
I'm,
you know,
I'm so focused on conservation and
habitat and being aware,
and it's not,
and it's not ever present,
but I,
I have this awareness of when I go and
hunt someplace that,
you know,
am I,
am I actually doing something good here?
Am I,
you know,
I won a few years ago to Newfoundland,
a hunt woodland Caribou and the
population was really down.
And so I got,
I got invited to go there.
And,
and um,
so I started looking into it because of
the population has done.
It's like,
man,
should I ever even really be doing this?
And I,
through my research I found out this
population of Caribou was really sick
lick.
And as they fall really low,
they thrive.
It's,
it's one of the best times for the
Caribou.
And actually when their populations are
at a huge boom,
they do the worst.
And so,
uh,
I wanted,
cause they too much of the lichens.
Yeah.
So they just,
their resource just starts to be
overlaid in,
then they have another,
another Boston.
So,
um,
so I went and did it.
But there's,
there's a constant ying and Yang and,
and as a hunter,
as a,
as a vegetarian,
even if you want to claim veganism,
all of these things,
we should be asking ourselves big
questions.
This whole thing that everything lives
here in a gray area.
There is no black and white.
I'm not against vegetarians and not
against vegans.
If a Vegan comes up to me and says,
how in the hell can you kill an animal
and wear leather shoes?
I say,
shit,
that's a really good point.
I'd let me ask myself cause I'm going to
have to sit down in a quiet float tank
and think about myself.
Like what I should be asking myself some
of these big questions.
And as it should,
they,
I just think there's a lot of
information that we should keep asking
ourselves,
keep asking ourselves because if the
population of human beings continues
exponentially,
which it will until this major event
that I,
uh,
that everyone thinks is calming
hunters should almost be the first ones
to give up hunting.
If,
if it trends towards that someday.
if it gets to be,
there's not enough wildlife or wild
lands or something fantastic happens.
Like hunters should be the first ones.
They should be on the front line of
being aware of the habitat and the
resources and say,
hey,
you know what,
we need to back off.
And,
um,
and I've seen it before.
It's actually really cool.
Few,
few years ago,
this is a micro instance,
but a few years ago,
actually a few years ago,
I say it's long time ago,
1991,
a huge blizzard hit in Wisconsin,
um,
on Halloween Day.
And,
um,
the Wisconsin deer hunters association
shut down whitetail hunting overnight.
He said,
there is no deer hunting this year.
It's canceled.
It's done.
There's no legal deer hunting this year.
And then all of these deer hunters,
we're taking their tractors out on these
public lands and on their private lands
and plowing areas for the deer to walk
around in the deer to move around.
And,
and so there's,
there's all sorts of instances about it.
But you get what I'm saying?
I think we have to keep asking ourselves
these questions as we,
as we move through our time and space.
I think it's real important.
And what you said about,
you know,
what you're essentially saying is that
people,
the,
and this is always been my problem with
people that proselytize or people that
are,
uh,
that are really into proclaiming that
they have the moral high ground because
they only vegetables.
That high ground is filled with holes.
You're going to step in one of those
holes if you keep talking because the
more angry you get at people that hunt
and the more angry you get,
the people that eat meat.
You have to understand that if you're
eating vegetables,
just by fact that you're buying them
from a factory farm,
you're buying them from large scale
agriculture.
You're absolutely responsible for death
and the death of fish.
I'm glad you brought that up because
those dead zones in the ocean that it,
that's a gigantic problem.
Oh my God.
It's a gigantic problem and it's,
it's a problem that is caused in large
part by large,
large scale agriculture.
As you said.
I think that one of these problems is
going to be solved by factory created
meet.
The problem is how many other problems
are going to be created by that?
I don't even mean jen like made me like
out of soy.
Oh No,
no,
no.
They're,
they're making meat in laboratories.
Laboratory created meat and they're
what?
They're,
I don't know exactly what the process
is,
but it's flesh cellular base.
Like what's the first thing that they
find?
The Patriot,
essentially they're cloning beef and all
these different things and the ideas
that they're going to be able to do this
without anything dying it.
So if you think,
if you think our population,
if you think our human growth is
exponential now,
now,
now we can get rid of the land now we
don't need the land now.
There's no value for wild places and
there's no value even for farms.
Now we can get rid of all of that.
And billionaires,
billionaires off,
they love money and so billionaires will
buy up all this land because they
already have all the money to buy the
land.
They'll buy the land,
they'll get the farms and they'll get
all of the wild places out and they'll
build even more houses.
Because you can eat some beige colored
grool or laboratory design meet and we
can get even more people.
Well I don't think they're thinking
about it that way.
Uh,
but so I just invented something.
This is,
I'm,
I'm sure.
I mean it's like,
it's like the idea of they like they're
going to do this and then,
well they're us and there's wildlife and
wild lands are protected.
There's federal land and you can't
really build factory farmed meat houses
on those places.
But now I see what you're saying.
But there's also the real problem with
like what,
what?
There's no,
there's no free ride.
Like what happens when you make that
meat?
Like what,
what's that time asking you?
What's the first thing in the Petri
dish?
Right.
And what's the cost of doing this also,
is there some sort of a side effect to
eating that meat?
Is it,
does it have negative health effects?
Is it have a negative environmental
effect?
It's like what is,
is there any sort of like waste product
that's created by,
by creating this meat?
I don't know.
These are all questions that have to be
answered.
None of it's clean now.
This is what's really important to like
when you run an Arrow through a bull elk
and that thing,
you know,
runs 20 yards and falls down and dies.
There's this weird feeling that you
have,
like there's a weird feeling of loss
that goes along with this weird feeling
of happiness that you're successful.
It's,
there's not,
there's,
there's no like one or zero.
It's not a binary experience.
It's,
it's not clean.
It's like life itself.
Life eats life.
And if you want to claim the moral high
ground because you're a vegetarian or if
you want to claim the moral high ground
because you're a hunter,
I think,
I think you're missing the big picture.
There is all this weirdness to life and
that there is this thing that we do that
we consume and that every other animal
does as well.
That's the thing that always strikes me
as being strange is the
people have a real hard time with people
eating predators are people hunting
predators like bear hunting is one of
the number one,
uh,
most sure fire ways to get people angry
at you online.
And it's,
there's a lot of ignorance attached to
a,
particularly with black bears,
which are responsible for literally
killing 50% of all the moose calves and
all the,
the,
the deer fawns and elk calves.
50% of them get whacked by,
by black.
They're very successful at calving
season.
Yeah,
they,
they have,
uh,
how strong is their nose?
It's some,
it's like a bloodhound is thousands of
times stronger scent.
Uh,
well then a or then us and then a black
bear measurably above that measure be
above this so they can smell like,
the way I try to explain it to people,
it's like,
you know how you smell skunk?
Like if you're driving your car,
you can smell it as fucking skunk for
blocks.
Now a black bear can do that with your
foot odor.
Yes.
Yeah.
Literally can smell.
You can smell the mustard on a hamburger
and pick it out from the beef and the
pickles.
It's even better than that because some
biologists are surmising that they
actually can tell time,
put their nose.
So when they walk in,
you know,
like you and I are driving on the road
and we go,
oh my God,
you smell that skunk.
Well,
he sitting there as he strolls through
the neighborhood,
he's gone.
Oh my God.
A skunk was hit by a car this morning.
But yesterday a little fat kid threw a
cheeseburger out of the window here.
And two days ago a woman with really
strong perfume walked down the sidewalk
with a poodle.
So they are literally,
there's so many layers to what they're
taking in and everything has it's,
you know,
essentially like different strengths
because of how long it's been president
of the area that they can almost kind of
read a book as they're strolling through
their environment.
And so it's that,
how do they know that they can do that?
I think they're just making a summations
off of like how powerful their noses are
and that they're picking up so much
information that they're picking up old
information,
current information,
brand new information.
And,
and,
and I mean,
if you think about that,
all of that information coming in their
head in an instant,
every instant,
every time they breathe in.
So that I think scientists are probably
making a summation that these bears have
to processes information as they're
going through because otherwise they'd
run scared.
I'll all day.
Right.
It's incredible.
They're incredible animals.
But it's interesting how many delicious
they are.
They good.
Are they delicious?
People don't want to hear that though.
You eat bears.
Yup.
You eat a bear.
So I have this thing where I've hunted
with several hunting guides,
several bear hunting guides where I've
convinced they've never eaten bear meat.
Some of these guys that are guides,
like they send them meat home with their
clients where they get it or they donate
it.
But I say,
if you guys ever eaten,
bear me.
I,
you know,
they mean the bears here,
they have,
you know,
like worms and they're,
they're fat as yellow in there and you
know,
and I say,
you're full of crap.
And so I did a hunt two years ago with a
very dear friend of mine.
I won't mention his name cause he'd be
mortified as he should be.
But I said,
hey,
um,
let's eat some bears.
And,
and when,
when I get there and we kill
a bear,
and he's like,
what if you don't kill a bear?
I said,
I'll tell you what.
He had a few bear hunts before me.
I said,
please,
he kills.
I'm very old bears.
And I said,
please save the ratty.
Just bear that you kill for us the
oldest,
nastiest looking bore,
please save,
um,
uh,
ask the archer or the hunter if we can
steal one of his hindquarters.
And he did and he let us.
And when we got there,
he pulled it out of the trash bag.
He had in a trash bag in there and
they're hanging cooler.
He pulled out of the trash bag and that
the fat was yellow and it looked
horrible.
And he told me that when he was skinny
and he actually saw some worms
underneath the,
you know,
the high devs.
Um,
yeah,
it's a constant.
And so,
uh,
so we made it that night along with some
big horn sheep and,
uh,
which is fantastic eating and all of the
big horn,
uh,
several pieces of the big Horn river
left.
The bear was long gone.
It was absolutely amazing.
And guys cook it.
Um,
we did it two ways.
One,
one day or one way we did it,
cause we were kind of having a dinner
party at a cabin.
And so we may just these little tiny
medallions and,
um,
it was really funny to his,
his reaction.
So then we just pan seared it with
butter and garlic and onions and just
ate at like little whatever chicken
mcnuggets if you will.
And he ate.
Then he's like,
well,
yeah,
I mean you combine anything with butter
and onions and garlic and it's going to
taste good.
And I'm like,
do you hear yourself?
So I mean,
it's going up to a chef and be like,
Oh yeah,
you made me codfish but use dill and
Manet's and yeah,
you're a little,
you're a liar.
You know?
And then so,
so then that night we made this big
roast and we seared it all sides,
right?
And seasoned it all up,
made a nice robin and put it in this
broth with vegetables and everything and
hate that.
And then of course,
he's like,
well,
I mean you made a rob and you sear it.
And I'm like,
well,
if you suck at cooking,
it's not the bears fault.
Like bear meat's delicious.
I'm not telling you to eat it raw off
his skeleton the moment you're skinning
him.
But if you take the time to,
uh,
prepare the flesh when you,
when you're in the field and then cook
it,
well,
it's amazing.
It's right up there with anything you're
dealing with is internal biases.
Yeah.
He's,
he's got these biases and he's just had
them and held onto them forever.
And especially if you're skinning
something,
you see worms didn't get grossed out and
you already think it's weird.
I know Rinella told me a story once
about a bear that he shot and killed and
was cooking on a friend smoker.
And he told the friend,
he goes,
man,
uh,
you got to clean that fucking smoker
out.
And the guy's like,
were you talking about?
He goes,
man,
that's smoker,
smelled like fish.
And he goes,
I'd never cooked the fish on that smoker
ever.
Like,
what are you talking about?
And he's realizing that the bear that he
killed had just been eating nothing but
fish.
Yeah.
And he said that when he was eating it,
it was a like eating smoked fish.
Like it was really good.
Yeah.
But it,
but it was this weird taste because it
was like,
you're eating this red meat that tastes
like smoked fish.
It's wicked.
They're awesome.
They're awesome if you had a blueberry
bear.
But yes,
I've never had that.
I've heard of the most incredible meet
on the planet earth.
In fact,
I got dropped off,
um,
I don't know,
four or five,
six years ago,
I was in the Arctic,
uh,
for 30 or so days in the pilot dropped
us off and he goes,
hey,
um,
do you have a bear tag?
And I said,
yeah,
I have a bear tag.
And he's like,
if you kill a bear,
he's like,
just tons of bears where I'm dropping
you off.
And he's like it.
Tons of grizzlies,
tons of black bears,
which is uncommon.
But he's like,
if you kill a black bear,
he's like,
and you don't want the meat,
I'll take it.
You know?
He'd made it very clear before he even
dropped us off and I said,
no,
we'll,
we'll keep it,
but we'll,
we'll share with you for sure.
We'll definitely share some with you,
but it's phenomenal.
Yeah.
Rinella was telling me that it's the
literally the greatest meat on earth.
Like when you have a bear that's been
eating nothing but blueberries,
and he did a,
an episode immediate or once we shot
one,
and as he's opening it up,
you see purple fat.
Yeah,
because the bears have been eating
blueberries for so long.
Their fat is purple.
And it made me think about my own diet
quite honestly,
because if this thing tastes so good and
smell so good because of what it's
eating,
if you're eating like fucking
cheeseburgers and fries,
like that's gotta be in your fat.
Let's get all that bullshit food,
you know,
fucking donuts that's gotta be in your
cells.
Like you literally are what you eat.
We know it.
But do you internalize it?
I think when you see a bear that has
purple fat,
maybe you internalize it even more.
I think so,
yeah.
I mean,
anytime you're able to spend,
you know,
uh,
you're,
you're dismantling and animal or
something like that.
You actually get to see these things.
Yeah.
If you have this same perspective or
wherewithal that we were talking about a
few minutes ago,
that's when you sit there and go,
well,
wait a minute.
You're not just mindlessly skinning this
bear.
You're sitting there going,
is my fat look like skittles?
Right.
Pounded a bag of skittles yesterday.
I heard they,
they,
they are gross though.
If they've been eating like a rotten
moose,
I've heard of you.
If you eat a bear that's been eating
rotten meat,
that it's pretty fucking gross.
I've heard that too,
but I've eaten them and it was fine.
Yeah.
What you ate one that ate or rotten
moves.
Well I've eaten one that is,
he was eating a rotten whale.
The whale was like a whale was like
orange,
orange and yellow.
They do that,
right?
Like a whale gets beached,
it dies like living it.
They'll crawl right up inside of its rib
cage and they come out looking like they
sound too much hair gel and just
everything that's so foul.
We actually good.
Yeah.
How did you cook it at?
Same,
same way that actually I did more
medallions that way because I was
backpacking so I ate it right on the
beach.
When you talk about bear hunting,
you really,
you're going up against years of movies,
you know,
years of fucking Yogi and booboo and
people have this weird perception of
what a bear is and we are the only
things they keep their population in
check.
The only things if you care about deer
and if you care about Moose and if you
care about other wildlife,
Predator control is the,
it's a real problem there.
One of the most ethical animals are
really
to hunt.
There are a lot of them there.
And,
and you have to like,
you have to be careful though,
right?
I mean,
they need to be controlled in certain
areas,
certain areas.
There's probably a decent balance cause
there's not a lot of,
um,
there's not a lot of food,
so they might not be focusing on Moose
calves,
rakes or might not be a lot of moose or
something like that.
But in areas where there's great
overlap,
like it's definitely,
there's,
they don't get killed a lot.
Right.
And so people don't hunt them a lot in
general and,
um,
and,
and people just,
you know,
they,
they instantly go to the ungulates,
right.
Instantly go to the deer and the Moose
and Caribou,
things like that.
But yeah,
there's definitely need to be managed.
The place I hunted,
I was bear hunting last week in BC and
the place I was hunting hasn't really
been hunted in like 10 years.
And you just know that these bears are
so terribly successful at stealing mule
deer,
fawns and Moose calves in this area and,
and um,
and I've seen it before and you just see
them.
Like,
I killed a grizzly bear a few years ago.
That was,
um,
I shouldn't say I killed it.
We,
it charged us.
And so the guy that I was with,
he had to shoot it.
Um,
and so he killed it.
But as soon as the bullet hit the bear,
he pooped out to,
to call Moose calves.
And we had,
we had s we had seen a cow with two
calves,
two twins,
and then,
um,
he was just cruising up and down the
river.
And so he,
he definitely got them.
And then when we kill them,
he'd,
and then,
um,
I wasn't even really thinking much about
it and just didn't have this wherewithal
of what was going on.
And it was kind of intense,
um,
situation when it went down.
But later on we were talking to the
biologist about it when we were having
the bear skull and hide and meet sealed
and um,
and we told him that he picked out a
calf and he's like,
oh,
fantastic.
Because there are grizzly bears and
black bears that are really successful
fon and calf killers.
And then there are others that aren't
right there.
They're kind of individualistic like we
are.
And,
and so he's like,
it's really good that you're moving this
big old board who was a successful calf
killer.
Cause he,
he would just fixate on that in the
spring.
And really it does not take,
like a lot of people might think,
oh,
there's millions of Moose up.
No,
there aren't.
And you go up in these areas like,
um,
people ask me all the time when we're up
in Alaska,
they're like,
oh,
when you get off the airplane,
there's got to be just animals
everywhere.
No,
there are no animals.
You get off the airplane in the Arctic
and you'd take a look around and there's
nothing like,
you have to go with no trees.
There's no trees,
there's no moose.
There's no care,
but like you find them when you go
looking for it,
then you find them when you find this
little micro niche of habitat.
But by and large,
there's nothing there because there's,
you know,
there's not a ton of resources there.
And so like I think people think it's
the Serengeti and it and it's not.
And so if you have a successful grizzly
and he's preying on Moose and a
particular valley,
um,
he could really do some damage.
And where I was,
and I just hunted mountain line for the
first time in BC this winter and I was
talking to the biologist cause I had
great contention about doing it and they
showed that,
um,
I didn't want to run them with dogs.
I didn't want to shoot it out of a bait
and a tree.
Um,
I just had never interested me.
And so a buddy of mine just got his
first hunting concession in BC has been
a guide his whole life,
but he now has his own concession.
He has black bears and mule deer is the
guy that I was also just bear hunting
with.
But he said,
hey,
will you come up and do a lion hunt?
And I said,
no man,
it's not for me.
And he's like,
well,
you know,
you're kind of being a hypocrite right
now.
And I said,
well,
what do you mean?
He's like,
well,
you're always preaching that people
should ask themselves big questions and
people should kind of dive into,
you know,
this tornado or the storm and,
and experience things and ask themselves
and actually challenge their thought
process.
So who better to come up and go on a
lion hunt?
And if you have prejudice about it,
why don't you come up and do it?
And so you can see if your prejudice are
real or,
or not.
And so I did it and it was very eye
opening.
It was an incredible experience.
What was eye opening about it?
Um,
just the animals themselves.
You know,
it's,
it was,
um,
the enthusiasm around the hounds.
Like,
I kind of pictured this,
you know,
I had this,
Fox and the hound scenario built up in
my head,
you know,
like it felt for the same,
same stereotypes that non hunters and
anti hundreds were falling forward.
I was like,
oh,
he's hounds better kind of redneck.
And you know,
they're there,
they treat their dogs like crap and
they're,
and they're sending their dogs into this
line fight and it's,
it's gonna get rough and these dogs are
going to get beat up and scarred up.
And then finally you treat this lion and
in the hunter comes waltzing in with no,
no barrier of entry whatsoever.
No physical suffering whatsoever.
No mental suffering whatsoever.
Comes waltzing in and shoots this thing
out of a tree and take some photos and
then skins at out leaves the flesh and
moves on with their life.
And so I go up there and meet the hounds
men and,
and first of all,
my friend,
his name's Ben storic and um,
he's very gracious.
Hunteries,
very aware.
He's very kind to animals.
These has tremendous wherewithal,
which is why we continue to hunt
together.
But he,
uh,
so I go up there and meet as Holland's
man,
great guy.
His hounds are part of the family sleep
in the cabin with him,
great dog food,
great medical care every single night
when we'd get home.
Um,
in the scenario in which I killed the
line was also very rewarding for me as a
person.
We tracked him,
I'll use kilometers cause that's what we
were doing there.
But,
um,
we tracked him for like 21,
22 kilometers just by his track.
And it was really cool because this lion
had tore his back right track.
So it was kind of like a movie.
We'd see his tracks in the snow and
there's always a dime sized spot of
blood in his track.
And it was pretty cool cause we went and
spoke with some ranchers along this
river and they're like,
yeah,
he's,
he's sport killing deer,
which I didn't believe but I just want
to hear the ranchers a kind of summation
on it.
And they didn't want him,
the ranchers where I was really
surprised with the wrench or like,
you know,
we you to kill this cat because,
um,
he sport killing these deer.
But,
um,
we want ben to be very measured in how
he takes cats because they really love
cats in this area and they just want ben
to be cognizant of the animals.
He removes,
which he has anyway.
But they love cats just because they
just love the idea of them being there,
the wildlife,
the symbolism of the wild.
And then all these ranchers,
they raise cattle and they watch the
wolves,
um,
harass their cattle,
but they watch the cats will literally
walk right through a calf pen and the
cavs won't spend any,
they don't even look at the lion.
The cows aren't looking at the lion,
but the lion will just stroll right
through the pen and just carry on about
his day because he wants to kill a deer
and sheet.
That's,
that's what he wants to fixate on.
He doesn't want to deal probably with
Mama Cow.
But um,
so we track the same for 22 kilometers.
We actually got down on it,
um,
on top of a mule deer killed that they
had made the night before.
Um,
bumped it and it ran way up into the
mountains and these and these hills and
we tracked it all the way up there.
We tracked another four or five
kilometers and then that's when we
release the hounds and it was wicked to
see the enthusiasm in the hounds.
Like I just pictured something that was
going to be blood thirsty and like,
you know,
they,
they wanted to rip this cat apart.
But these hounds that the look on their
faces,
and I'm making,
making judgments here,
but the look on their faces were just
pure enthusiasm.
Like this is a game.
Like our job is to,
is the chase this cat down inside,
they've been trained and to,
and to get it in a tree,
like they're not sitting there going,
we're going to catch and kill this cat.
They're like,
our job is to kind of get it in the
tree.
You know,
it was just really cool to be around the
dogs and watched her energy.
And so they went and treated the line.
We snuck in on the line and he,
he,
uh,
he didn't like it and see,
he jumped off and the dogs and sued,
pursued again and then we treat him
again and I killed him.
And killing him was,
um,
neither here nor there.
It wasn't,
um,
it was just an act.
It was just,
uh,
a light switch for me.
It was,
um,
Ben Needs,
uh,
Ben had spoke with the biologists.
They wanted a certain amount of cats
removed from this area cause they were
really having predatory impact on the
sheep and the,
and the deer.
And I kind of found out why afterwards,
when I spoke to the biologist.
But,
um,
we got him in three and ben just like,
Hey,
he's a big Tom and he's an old tom and,
um,
so we're going to kill him anyway,
so if you want to kill him,
kill him.
If not,
we're going to kill him.
You know,
and they had tags to everything was
legal and I said,
no,
I'll kill him.
Um,
I wanted to take the process all the way
through,
so I killed him.
He died very quickly.
Um,
and I'd always heard that their meat was
really good.
And,
um,
I'd also heard people say it's on the,
so of course I don't kill anything
unless I'm going to eat it.
So,
uh,
we ate it and it was arguably the finest
meat I'd ever had in my life.
It's another thing.
Rinella told me,
he said,
it tastes like pork you've ever had.
Well,
I'm not even a big fan of pork.
Like I like pork,
but it was pork is okay.
Mountain lion is like succulent flavor,
deep rich pork.
It's just absolutely unbelievable.
Um,
their fat is supposed to be really good
as well.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
And,
and,
uh,
so it was just really rewarding
experience for me.
And like,
then I got to hang out with the dogs
afterwards.
And then when I went and spoke with a
biologist that was eye opening as well
because,
um,
the hounds when we're with,
he kind of gets the cat to be like five
or six years old,
which would be very old.
It turned out to be three.
And which is amazing that they go from a
kitten to this thing was like 170 580
pounds.
Um,
and that big,
that big and just three years.
And the biologist even told me he had
one come in earlier that year that was
over 200.
It was like two oh two,
two or three,
which is about as big as they get.
And it was radio collared and he's like,
oh,
this is going to be wicked because we
have the radio collar,
I'm going to be able to call the
biologist that radio collared this
thing.
It's 200 pounds of thing.
It's gotta be like five or six,
seven years old.
He called the guy and the thing was,
um,
just had barely leaves,
like just over two years old.
And he's already 200 pounds.
Two years old.
Yes.
And they're just so,
and,
and with,
um,
you know,
like sometimes aging dear aging bears is
kind of a tricky prospect.
You're looking at the molar where,
and you're looking at their lateral and
sizes and they're,
um,
medial incisors and you're looking at
where and everything with the lions,
it's very easy to see like they have the
age classes have distinct dental changes
that happen.
Like it's,
it's,
there's,
there's kind of no middle ground.
And so,
you know,
and of course the radio collar they
knew,
but they're just so terribly successful.
And just looking at the amount of
biomass they put on their bodies,
just their size and how they carry a
fucking forearms
arms or like a human thigh.
That's what freaked me out because I'm
sitting there holding,
this thing's
gone out body,
it's going to wear to skin,
skin and body.
And uh,
it weighs the exact same as a deer.
Like it's the same thing as a deer,
but the proportions are way off.
Right.
The thing is so much shorter.
The meat,
you know,
it goes all the way down to their paws
so they can jump,
you know,
30 feet out of a tree and land and just
like you and I would be rolling around
on the ground going,
oh my God,
look at my femur.
And these guys just boom.
And they're off to the races and it's
just,
you know,
you drop it,
they weigh the same as the deer.
You drop a deer out of a train,
it's going to have four broken legs.
These things just land and off to the
races,
the animals.
And so,
and so I was gonna say,
so the sport killing,
so the biologist told me where the area
where there's a lot of wolves and so the
wolves,
the lines are so much more successful at
killing and the wolves that the wolves
just become somewhat lazy and they'll
get in these little packs and the
literally find a big Tom and they'll
just follow him.
And so what this cat is doing is
scientists have observed him killing
deer and he'll literally kill and cash
dear and sheep.
So that when the wolves find his caches,
the wolves will eat.
And so then he can now he can go and eat
in peace himself so he doesn't get
fucked with by the wolves.
So he's leaving them food,
he's leaving them food,
which is why the ranchers thought cause
they're like,
he killed a deer and you didn't do
anything with it.
He just killed a deer.
And so they're like,
no,
no.
He killed a deer.
And it's funny cause when we tracked him
that day,
he brought us to nine kill sites that
day.
Wow.
Yep.
So he's literally doing that while
you're chasing,
I'm saying,
look,
just eat this.
Leave me the fuck alone.
Yeah.
So as,
as you're tracking him,
he's tracking you pass spots,
hoping that you take his cash and leave
him alone.
Yep.
Wow.
It was a fantastic experience.
And then the biologist also told me,
and I was like,
man,
I had a lot of contention and I'll come
in here and hunting lions.
And I had,
you know,
I don't know how successful they are at
repopulating,
you know,
we almost hunted them to extinction.
At the turn of the century and they're
just starting to kind of make,
they're starting to expand now back into
their,
some of their original territories.
Um,
but he's like,
hey man,
Donnie,
he's like,
this is a great animal to take.
This is an area that receives very
little lion hunting.
We have to take some of these lines out.
And he showed me data that they had on
this one lion,
and I don't want to misquote the data,
but basically the single line had
removed like nine or 11% of this
particular sheep herd in a year.
Just like boom,
boom,
boom.
And this dude knew the game.
He knew where to kill,
he knew how to kill and he had no
chance.
I mean,
he's just a super pressed.
You have no chance.
If he finds them,
he's going to kill them.
Yeah.
The runs faster.
He's stronger.
And if he gets a hold of them,
they never,
they never lose.
It's never like a,
like a deer gets away.
No,
they,
they win every time.
No.
So it was,
so,
it's right on the same like,
you know,
same path.
Has all the predators.
It's like,
you know,
you just,
it leads to really good discussions,
but people get upset when you kill
predators.
They get very upset.
What's,
it's really strange because they don't,
they don't have any problem with the
Predator killing deer and they have less
problem with people killing deer.
But they have a real problem.
People killing predators and I believe
it's the same problem they have with
like cecil the lion and shit like that.
They think that you're just doing it to
be an asshole and you just want this
thing on your wall.
Well I went ahead on your wall.
I do have some contention and you tell
me and like,
like for instance like the grizzly bear
issue being shutdown and BC,
there's a bear grizzly bear hunting.
Maybe you can explain that for me.
People don't understand what's going on
with that.
Yeah.
So,
so the government,
the British Columbia government
shutdown,
British Columbia,
British Columbia grizzly bear hunting
because they equated it and I guess
they're probably correct with trophy
hunting,
right to where it hunters,
we're killing these animals and just
taking the skulls and hides and leaving
the flush behind.
And,
um,
and I don't know,
I've never,
uh,
have I at Grizzly bear hunting NBC
wants,
but I was actually more on a sheep hunt.
But,
um,
yeah,
just this notion of like,
like the gentleman that killed cecil the
lion,
like if you're really going to kill an
animal and,
uh,
just take its hide,
then I've pretty significant issue with
that.
And so like I,
I just hope hunters that
the guys are hunting the grizzly bears.
I just,
I wonder if this was more of a hunter
instilled issue then,
then,
um,
people are even bringing light into it.
Cause if people were killing grizzly
bears in British Columbia,
taking their hides,
taking their skulls and taking all of
the flesh,
I feel like we'd still be grizzly bear
hunting in British Columbia.
I don't know.
I mean maybe,
maybe,
but grizzly bears are another notch up
even above black bears in terms of like,
correct.
Yeah.
Rinella calls charismatic megafauna.
People love those things cause they
liked seeing them.
And if you don't have to deal with them,
if you're not like that,
a guy in ennis,
Colorado last year,
they've got his head cut open by one.
If you don't have to deal with them,
you know,
they,
they are amazing to look at and we all
want them around.
I mean,
of course they're an incredible animal,
but it's this thing of trophy hunting.
These what you think of some fat,
Lazy ass hole with a rifle that stands
on top of a lion.
You know,
there's this image that I found online
and uh,
I was looking at,
I was like,
that is,
that's why people have a problem with
trophy hunters.
Axonify this fat fuck,
who should never in a million years
without that rifle had,
have ever the help or the help,
especially the help,
right?
Like there's no way he would've got on
it.
There's no way to who had got to that
position.
He must've got there in a car,
you know,
and then they have this line in there
and he's perched up on the line like he
did some amazing thing.
Yeah.
And my my meanwhile,
that's probably one of those caged lines
anyway.
It is.
I mean,
yeah,
they have so many of those high fence
hunt where they let these lions,
they have them all caged up in a pen.
They throw a cows over the dead cows
over the pen,
over the wall,
the pen,
the lions tear them apart and then they
pick one and take that one out into the
wilderness area,
which all fenced in anyway.
And then they let it loose and then the
lions stays in the area because it has
no idea what its boundary is,
what its territory is,
what,
what other lines were in that area.
So a lot of times they sit still and
they wait for awhile before they figure
out what their territory is.
The hunter comes in,
shoots,
it stands on,
it takes a picture of me.
You just shot a pet.
If you,
if you told me,
he said,
hey man,
I went into Tanzania,
I went into,
you know,
the wildest part and uh,
backpacked in and set up camp and I was
there for 40 days and you know,
I killed,
killed an eight planes game and I worked
with the locals and,
and,
and you know,
I shared meet with these different
tribes and,
and man and we found a pride of lions
and there was a giant main to mail and
there was another sister pride over here
and,
and we,
you know,
we snuck in and we killed them.
We hunted him,
we killed him,
you know,
we skinned him out,
we took his flesh and we went on an
honest hunt and we engage the wild here
and we were moved into animal wicked.
I would love to read that book.
I'd love to see that film.
I'd love to hear you.
Tell me that story.
Does eat lions?
Why not?
That's what I'm saying.
I just,
anybody,
I don't know.
I never even heard of it.
I've never been to Africa.
And if and if you're not,
then what are we doing?
I understand killing it.
So there,
there,
there's,
there's some weirdness there too.
Cause if you told me,
if,
if you called me and said,
hey man,
I'm gonna pay you $1 million,
I want you to come down to my
concession.
I get these offers daily,
not $1 million,
but if you come down,
will you come down on my concession and
shoot a giraffe?
I'm just making this up,
but I'm trying to pick a zoo animal.
Well,
you come down and shoot a giraffe.
Um,
I'd love to see come down and film this,
Blah Blah and,
and uh,
you know,
the is no,
I have no explaining a concession to
people to this large areas that are most
of the time fenced in lot of thousands.
It's thousands,
maybe even tens of thousands of acres.
Like you're never going to see the
fence.
We could drive you around in there for a
week and you never see it.
So it's,
unless I'm my wild.
Yeah,
the fence thing is very weird,
right?
Because like their habitat,
the fence essentially keeps people out.
Yeah.
It protects them from poachers.
It's not,
it's not necessarily to trap the
animals,
although the animals can't leave.
It's to keep the poachers out.
It's to preserve these areas because
people
with greed will take,
they'll kill anything that get a few
dollars in the marketplace for,
for market meat.
And then certainly to sell a hide to
maybe even a even more fat hunter that,
or person that calls themselves a hunter
that wants a lion on their wall that
doesn't even want to engage in the
process.
Right.
They'll buy the skin or something.
It's why there's trading tiger skins and
things like this.
But,
um,
so in these concessions,
and so these,
you know,
if you called me and said,
hey,
will you come down and shoot a giraffe,
um,
you know,
pay 1 million bucks to come down and
shoot a draft.
You know,
the answer's no,
I don't want to kill a giraffe.
But if you called me and said,
hey,
um,
we have restored this habitat in this
whole river delta,
and Lo and behold,
the giraffes have absolutely taken off
and they're very,
very successful and they're decimating
the vegetation here and they're starting
to fight each other with,
um,
great severity and were finding dead
bowls and stuff.
We need to remove 10 animals from this
hurdle.
You come down and shoot 10 drops with
me,
100%.
Absolutely.
Like if I can come down and contribute
to the ecology of an area,
either as a hunter or as somebody that's
just removing animals with a high
powered rifle to create some more
balance,
I'm all into it.
But if I'm going to pay you $70,000 to
get a big main line so I can have my
photo with a big main lion,
um,
that I can show my friends,
be like,
oh yeah,
that's when I was in Botswana and that's
all I could tell you that story.
And I had no interest in it.
And I think some of that stuff is
maybe really poisonous for hunting.
I think it's very poisonous.
I think that Cecil the lion story,
it was incredibly poisonous.
Yeah.
It was one of those stories where it was
almost to
find any support for the guy who did
that thing and you know,
and it was legal.
It was,
I mean,
you know,
people say,
what was the collared lion yet blown?
You can't really tell like they have
giant mains.
Even if it was,
it doesn't mean anything.
You can shoot color an animal's yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
they're not collared because they're
protected.
It's not like the idea is like you could
never shoot it because it's collared.
Yeah.
And you know,
um,
it's the,
it's just not what people [inaudible].
There's,
it's real hard to justify if you're not
eating it.
I mean,
why,
why would you want to do it?
Why would you want to go and hunt a
lion?
It doesn't make any sense.
You'd have to be an asshole.
That guy not asking himself any
questions.
I'll tell you that.
Right?
Yeah.
Right.
Why is he doing it?
He's doing it because that's what he
likes to do.
And so that's why I wonder,
like,
I haven't grizzly bear hunting in
British Columbia,
but I wonder,
and I'm not,
I have lots of friends that are,
that are guides and outfitters.
And I understand that the meat,
um,
I've heard it's gross.
I've heard it's gross too,
but I've eaten it.
How is it fantastic.
Yes.
You know,
again,
John,
you know John Barklow from Sitka?
Uh,
I've,
I think I've met him.
I think I've met him just telling me
that he,
uh,
he served people a brown bear meat at
his,
uh,
at a party once,
like kid cooked it and put it in,
made it like little hors d'oeuvres and
he didn't tell people what it was.
And you're like,
this is really good.
What is it?
And I was like,
oh,
it's a brown bear.
And they got real mad at him making me
bear,
but they liked it.
Yeah.
So we,
so we,
um,
I was hunting a brown bears on Kodiak
island a few years ago and I didn't,
I didn't kill one.
Um,
but when we got done,
there was a guy there,
a classically trained chef that lived in
town and he had,
uh,
him and his buddies had killed a bear.
And so he invited us over for dinner and
when we were in town and he served as
brown bear and it was amazing.
Absolutely amazing.
How do you cook it?
He did it several different ways,
but one of the ways he did it,
uh,
that was really amazing.
And again,
this is all in preparation,
right?
But he made kind of like Swedish
meatballs,
so he probably,
and he,
and he told us that the preparation was
intensive,
so he made a bath,
a whole milk bath,
put the bear meat in it,
let it sit for 10 hours,
dump the milk,
output more whole milk.
And he did that like four or five times
to just leech anything that was in the
meat out.
Right.
Probably blood in any sort of,
um,
I don't know
if you could be elk.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if that's doing that with bass,
like taking baths filets and catfish
filets and putting them in milk.
Yeah.
And would it be something along the
lines of Osmosis?
Would it be that the milk has a greater
density?
So the,
so the blood wants to leave the meat and
go into that and create asking the wrong
guy.
I really have no idea.
That's just me guessing.
I don't either.
But anyway,
and then he pants here to a bunch of it
and it was like a roast,
if you will.
But he did it all in a really hot cast
iron skillet and it was phenomenal.
And then I just heard somebody the other
day,
um,
what was I listening to?
I was,
I was reading something about polar bear
hunting
and somebody was remarking that a polar
bear was really good to eat.
And so I think there's a lot of um,
misinformation out there about what is
edible and what is not edible and what
is good and what isn't.
And probably because of the preparation
because people think so.
I've been ignorant about how to prepare
and key up me.
Yeah.
Cause I have people that think I have
lots of friends.
I think deer meat's disgusting.
Soak fish and milk for odor free
cooking.
Hmm.
Okay.
So it says when you're buying fish,
okay,
here's the science.
Try to say that word.
Try methylene trimethylamine oxide.
Trimethylamine oxide oxide is a common
chemical in living things.
It's colorless,
odorless,
and produced by normal metabolic
processes.
When a fish or shellfish is killed,
however it breaks down into
trimethylamine,
which is the chemical responsible for
that fishy smell that we know so well.
If your cut of fish isn't too far gone,
as the flesh is still from and only a
few days thought at most,
a quick soak about 10 to 20 minutes and
a bowl of milk will help get rid of that
odor like casing.
Okay.
How'd he say it?
Is that Cassie or Casey?
I've heard it both ways.
I've never heard it.
I only read it.
Yeah.
C A s e I n in the milk bonds with the
tri methylene.
And while it's not a full extraction,
a quick soak can pull a good bit amount
of the flesh,
reduce the odor.
So that's probably what's going on.
You're reducing the odor and the meat
and it just probably re enhancing the
flavor and doing something,
especially with a stinky as Baird's meat
and fish.
And this one definitely had,
I think.
Yeah,
well the big ones especially,
I mean that's one of the reasons why the
grow so big on Kodiak rights because
they have so much access to fish and
short,
um,
short torpor short hibernation.
Yeah,
that's crazy,
man.
Yeah,
I've never,
I've never eaten grizzly.
I've eaten brown bear or black bear
rather.
Um,
uh,
my friend John and Jen,
they have a camp up in Alberta and we,
uh,
oh sure eight.
Do you know them?
The Rivets?
I don't,
I don't know the,
uh,
they have a camp up in Alberta and great
black pair of hunting and jen is a
really good cook and she made this black
bear stir fry.
And even people that were skeptical,
they were like,
oh,
okay.
I've never eaten bear before.
They're like,
holy shit,
this is fantastic.
She cooked this stir fry and then serve
it over rice.
I mean,
it is,
it's amazing.
It was so good and so good for you.
The way I explain it to people,
it was like,
it's a d like a deer fucked a pig.
That's what the meat tastes like.
And maybe it's cousin was a cow.
Like it's,
it's a strange,
it's not a meat that tastes like
anything you could put your thumb on.
Like,
oh,
like that's just like this.
Yeah.
It's just like,
that's just really rich and it's,
it's just,
yeah,
it's fantastic.
And Yeah,
at bear hunting all the way around,
it's just awesome.
Yeah.
But it's,
again,
it's so charged,
it's so charged in the public eye in
terms of like how people perceive it.
It's one of those animals.
And I think it's because of these movies
that people grow up with these movies
where these animals are our friends,
you know,
and they're looking out us and they're
our buddies.
And it's just like we've done ourselves
knows service by doing that,
by creating these films that have
poisoned little kids' minds as to what
these animals are and what these animals
are are opportunists and predators.
And they are there to remove the weak
and the,
the limping and the babies and anything
else he can get his hands on for
population control.
I mean this is the balance of nature.
If we still were hunters and gatherers,
right,
there would not be,
there was not a single anti hunter in
that group.
Right?
There was no,
that guy didn't live,
there is no room for that guy.
So even,
you know what I talked about in our
short film,
who we are,
like the president of Pida comes from a
strong group of hunters and gatherers.
Otherwise the dude wouldn't be here like
to play devil's advocate,
their thought process and the thought
process of vegans and vegetarians are
that,
if I could speak for them,
is that we're moving past that we're
moving past animal cruelty.
We're moving past that need to eat and
consume meat.
Right.
I,
I disagree.
I think we have,
um,
through infrastructures of Safety and
laziness we've set,
we've set it up so that you can go down
that road if you want.
Um,
we've shut this up so you don't have to,
um,
break.
And you know,
you never have to crack an egg.
If you have enough money,
you never have to crack an egg in your
entire life and you can eat eggs your
entire life so you can back away from
who we really are.
As you know,
if you have the financial wherewithal or
you live in New York City or you live in
La,
you can back off of the real muddiness
as far as you want.
But in true reality,
this is really who we are.
It's just that we have infrastructures
now that make up for it,
that make you,
that allow that disconnection.
They allow you to,
to say,
hey,
we move past this now.
Like I can get my coffee at the corner
and you know,
and,
and um,
and it's to go to Ethiopia,
right?
Yeah.
It's hard to argue,
right?
It's hard to argue.
And we did a piece,
um,
uh,
my production company,
Sick Manta,
we did a piece of years ago or last year
for epic meets.
Um,
have you ever heard of those guys?
If they do like high and Jerky and they
do like animal fats and they do bone
broths and things like that.
Anyway,
the owners were bars.
Those are delicious.
Yeah,
they're really amazing.
So the owners were vegans,
they are both vegans,
a husband and wife couple and,
and they're all,
they're both also triathletes.
And they were doing these races and they
were having a tough time recovering from
their races and they actually owned one
of the largest vegan food companies in
the country.
And they went to go see a friend who was
a medical doctor,
a friend of theirs.
And he said,
hey look,
I think you guys need to get some
really,
um,
high end,
uh,
animal fats in your systems to help your
body recover from these races.
And they started doing that and their
symptoms,
you know,
like their soreness or whether it be
back pain,
hip,
knees,
I'm assuming that was all from the
races,
um,
started to go away almost.
So they started
kind of delving into their psyche and
their questions and they started kind of
revisiting their philosophies,
if you will.
And,
and I,
I don't want to get the story wrong,
but I think while they still owned the
Vegan food company,
they started epic meets and they
thought,
can we find meat that is responsibly
grown and sourced for people that don't
want to kill it themselves?
And,
uh,
and they went down that road.
They ended up actually selling the Vegan
food company off because,
uh,
people found out that they owned both.
And I think there is obviously some
problems there.
Yeah.
But they,
but they just found,
um,
really good source for me and,
and uh,
they do all feel the harvest.
And so we did a,
we did a commercial production for them,
a branding piece for them,
um,
to kind of highlight how they treat
their animals and how they kill their
animals because they kill them.
Um,
rather than putting them on a truck and
loading them into crowds and doing that
whole thing,
they literally drive out with the same
tractor that they feed them with and
they've had them on huge pastures so
that they're actually,
I'm reclaiming the ground.
Um,
and it's really cool when they,
when they do ranches,
they'll go in and test all the soils of
these ranches and the grasses and then
they'll retest them after one year,
three years,
five years.
And they're finding even better soils
and better grasp as these animals.
I've spent time there because they're
doing,
um,
more fertilizing and,
and the grasses are being reclaimed.
And then,
um,
they shoot the animal in the head with a
high powered rifle.
And so they do just lights out,
boom.
Done.
And then that's how they booked from so,
so they do it right.
Do it
about as ethically and humanely as you
can kill an animal,
as you can kill an animal that's being
raised in a pen.
What was that place in la?
Was it called harmony cafes?
That what it was called?
What was the place where the people,
the owned it gratitude cafe gratitude,
right.
That's right.
There was,
um,
a place in la that was owned by these
people.
It still is,
but,
uh,
they were vegans for a long time and
they were having health issues as well.
And they decided to butcher their own
animals and start raising their own
animals and butchering them.
And uh,
I think they wrote about it on a blog
and they were just trying to explain
themselves and vegans went fucking
crazy.
The people that own the restaurant went
crazy and they've got a bunch of death
threats and yeah.
And it became this giant issue with
them.
Um,
it's,
you know,
I get where they're coming from.
They don't,
they,
they have this rigid idea of what's
happening and they don't want an animal
to die so that they can live.
I get it.
But their perception of the,
the ethical purity of their deciding to
just eat vegetables and the actual,
the actual health consequences in terms
of like how many people can get by and
what your,
your physical dietary needs are.
How many people can get by on just
eating a Vegan Diet,
especially if you're not like super
careful and using algae and all these
different things to get b12 and fat
soluble vitamins and you know,
you can get by.
But is it optimum for most people
according to most nutritionists and
people that aren't ideologues?
No.
Yup,
I agree.
He's,
no,
it's like we are herbivores.
I mean rather a omnivores and we're not
herbivores and some people that are in
the vegetarian world,
they want us to think that we are
basically herbivores and that we can get
by and then our desire to consume meat
is just because of the sickness that we
have and this is evil nature that,
you know,
human being sometimes are possessed by
it,
but it's just just not true.
Yeah.
There are the whole reason why we became
a human being in the first place as
opposed to like one of the lower
primates.
A lot of that is attributed to our
consumption of meat,
hunting,
meat,
cooking,
cooking with fire,
and it's such a fantastic,
like I would love
if I could do,
if I was a billionaire and you said,
hey,
do you want to continue along with the
career that you're on right now?
I absolutely would,
but the thing that I would love the most
is to take people with me.
Yeah,
a lot.
It's super hard for a Vegan to get into
that though.
I mean,
man,
you would have to,
they'd have to have some sort of desire
on their part.
Absolutely love life.
[inaudible] you could just like take
some flower child and you know,
it's only in sprouts and say,
Hey,
I'm going to go shoot this mule deer
through the lungs with a fucking yeah.
You know?
Yeah.
Mazy trocar.
Uh,
you're going to sit there and watch him.
Yeah.
No,
they would have to be,
have questions.
Yeah.
I mean,
there would have to be on that path
themselves.
It's just,
it's an interesting byproduct to me of
society of what we've done with this
really incredible infrastructure that
we've created where we can get food to
these 20 million people that live in La
and no one be a part of that preparation
in terms of,
uh,
you know,
getting the animal,
killing it,
serving it,
you know,
butchering it,
cooking it,
serving it.
We cut all that shit out and go right to
buying the meat that's already cooked.
Yeah.
And we've done it so much and it's so
much more prevalent than any of the
other steps.
You know,
most of the,
most of the consumption that most people
in this country,
like when we're talking about eating
meat,
I would say maybe even what is the
number?
I would like to know what the number is.
If I had a guess of how many people even
cook their own meat.
Hmm.
I mean,
how many people are getting most of
their meals from a store or a restaurant
or fast food?
Yeah.
Pretty prepped.
And how many people would,
I mean I didn't even think about fast
food.
That's gotta be the majority.
Yeah.
I mean,
how many people actually even cooking
their own meal?
We've cut out so many steps.
When I would,
I would bet it was probably more than
half.
Don't even cook their own meat.
Yeah.
I mean,
people,
they just don't have,
they just don't have an understanding of
where it comes from.
Right.
And engagement.
There's just no understanding
whatsoever.
It's hard subject.
And I just saw,
um,
flying here to meet with you.
I just saw a,
I think it was in the Minneapolis
airport,
there was a huge sign on the wall.
It was a picture of a massive,
massive cornfield and it may,
it may have been doctored up,
but it was corn as far as the eye can
see.
And it was for cargill,
a big car corporation out of Minneapolis
and then get out of Minneapolis.
But it said,
um,
it said,
preparing to feed 8 billion people.
And uh,
so I just see that sign.
I'm just like,
yeah,
that hell in a hand basket right there.
Corns,
fucking terrible for you.
Terrible.
Absolutely terrible.
And,
and,
and literally you can read that sign and
all these people be like,
oh,
that's so beautiful.
Like all those corn stalks and there'll
be food for us forever.
And why cook when you cannot the
percentage of diners or dinners rather
eaten at home that were actually made at
home in the u s and it's so weird having
you here.
Jamie's the shit.
This is weird.
This is just dinner.
So,
right,
so this is how many people are cooking,
but really that's the only meal.
Lower and lower.
So it's below,
it's somewhere in the 60% range.
So the percentage of it dinners eaten at
home that were actually made at home in
the u s somewhere around 60% so in that
60% you got to think there's the mom or
the dad that's cooking and then the kids
that are eating the food so they're not
cooking shit.
So it's probably way lower than that in
terms of the actual human beings that
are eating cooked food that they cook
themselves.
Yeah.
So how can you,
how can it,
how can you stand on a,
uh,
on any sort of laurels at all without at
least asking some questions?
I mean,
people that they've,
their answers are,
they feel better if they think that they
are doing no harm.
And the way to do no harm is to eat
vegan.
So this is the ideology behind it.
And I understand it.
I get it,
I appreciate it.
But the fucking anger at people who
don't follow that path is where it gets
real squirrely.
You know,
and it's a small number of people,
and I've talked about this in my act,
that the problem with vegans is the
problem with people,
it's not veganism,
it's people.
If you get a room that has a hundred
people in it,
the odds of one of those people being a
fucking idiot is 100% it's almost a
hundred percent that one of them is a
fucking idiot.
Yeah.
So if you get 300 million people,
you have 3 million fucking idiots and
some of those folks are vegans.
And that's the problem with veganism.
It's not,
it's not veganism itself.
It's there's a certain percentage of
human beings that they don't have to do
anything to become vegans.
Right.
They just joined this group.
It's not like you have it.
Well we're,
we're thinking about louring you in to
the Vegan culture,
but we want to know what your philosophy
is.
Are you a hateful person?
Are you a person who's looking to be a
Vegan?
So you could just talk shit about other
people?
Are you looking to be angry?
You're looking to be in a group or a
gang of plant based gang and put the
word Vegan in front of your name and
just start talking shit.
Cause that's a lot of the people.
Yeah.
And so people read all these angry,
hateful things that people,
right.
And they go,
oh well this is vegans.
But it's not,
it's not the,
most of the kids are not like that at
all.
Yeah.
People,
most people are not like that at all.
But there's a certain percentage of them
and they claim veganism and they usually
put that name,
the word Vegan in their fucking screen
name.
That's how you can spot those assholes.
Yeah.
Proud.
Yeah,
they're into it.
They're in a plant based gang.
Yeah.
That's really what happens.
And so what it is is not necessarily
even a problem of diet.
It's a problem of human nature is that
people love to stand on the moral high
ground.
They will love to point down to all the
other people,
whether it's a religious issue,
like you're not eating Halau or you're
not eating kosher or are you a,
you're eating meat on Good Friday.
Whenever the fuck it is,
they just decide that they have this
moral high ground that you don't have,
so fuck you.
I'm doing it right.
And it really comes from our own
questions of our own existence and this
messiness that we're all inherently
aware of that life eats life
big time.
Big Time.
There was a guy that I did a podcast
without a Maine and he was,
uh,
he was for sure a vegetarian.
He might've been a Vegan,
but then he started and he's a forge or
big time.
It's actually pretty remarkable what he
does.
But I think 99% of his food he finds in
the forest year round,
he's just into it.
Big Time process all of his food from
wild apples to acorns to tovar.
It's,
um,
what's his name?
Um,
what's Daniel vitality?
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
Daniel vitale's.
Okay.
Yeah.
Have you heard of him as well?
Yep.
So,
um,
so I did a podcast with him and he,
and he told me that,
um,
and he'd eat insects.
He didn't want it.
He has completely against hunting.
He didn't want to kill anything.
He's like,
that's why he's eating insects.
And he's like,
and I would get a little bit of hate
mail.
Um,
when I started eating a Damsel,
flies and dragonflies,
like I'd get a little bit of hate mail.
And then,
and then a friend of his was like,
Hey,
um,
you know,
we should,
let's go gig some frogs.
Let's go get some frogs,
you know?
And he's like,
yeah,
I dunno.
Okay,
so I'll do it.
So when he started catching frogs,
he's like,
man,
like there's a lot of meat on one of
these frogs.
Like it's,
it's,
it's like 20 dragonflies,
you know?
And,
and he got,
he got a little bit more flack for it.
And then it's a buddy of his wanting to
take him fishing and they caught a trout
and he's like,
oh my God,
this is like three frogs.
Like this is three frog.
And so what he's equating it to is how
much work he has to go through to get
this protein or to get this,
you know,
to get just plant,
like you find one apple that's 15
acorns,
you know.
And so like he's equating this to work.
And so he kept just kept moving up the
food chain.
And um,
and he's like,
and then one year he killed a Turkey and
he told me,
it's like I killed a snowshoe hare.
And he's like,
I was blown away at how much meat was on
a snowshoe hare.
He's like,
that was,
you know,
three meals for him and his girlfriend
try a moose.
Yeah.
And so he just kept moving up and killed
a Turkey.
Then this last year he killed a black
bear,
but he's like every stage that he's
moved up,
his hate mail is went up,
you know,
I have no horn exponentially,
but
significantly.
And so it's just,
people equate all of these things to,
you know,
they remember,
we relate more to mammals,
obviously we're mammals,
you know,
and then you bring in something like a
bear that has anthropomorphic,
you know,
mannerisms,
right?
You,
you watch a black bear for a half a day
and you're like,
you see your dad,
you're like,
oh,
I just sat on his ass for four hours
around sometimes on his toenails.
Yeah.
He's like itched his ear farted,
he pooped over there next to the girl
and then you know,
and you're like,
oh my God,
it's my dad hunting my dad.
You know,
and,
and so,
you know,
there's things like that,
but um,
that's where this,
I think that's where this really cool
engagement comes from with hunters.
It's,
and there's a lot of hunters,
like I talked to a lot of hundreds and I
don't want to be negative,
I'm trying not to be negative,
but I talked to a lot of hundreds that
have no,
I have nothing in common with them.
Absolutely nothing.
Like you hunt,
I hunt.
I don't even think we have that uncommon
because I see how you hunt.
And this had nothing to do with how I
sound like what we were just saying
about vegans,
that the problem is just being a human
being.
That's the amount of people that choose
to hunt that or they're not well
informed and they're fucking idiots.
Yup.
And so that's,
that's the stuff is like,
same with the vegans,
you know,
there's,
I'm sure there's vegans that sit at home
and just grab their face and go,
I can't believe somebody just said that.
I can't believe they sent a death
threat.
Yeah.
We're Vegan for God's,
one of my best friends is a Vegan and I
net words hilarious comedian.
He's a Vegan.
I know some vegans too.
And I actually know some vegetarians
that,
um,
you know,
it was an education for me,
but I had some vegetarians hit me up for
meat,
you know,
and I was like,
uh,
oh,
you're vegetarian.
And they're like,
well,
yeah,
we're not going to eat this meat,
but um,
we'd love to have some fish or deer meat
from you was like,
oh,
okay.
Now I'm starting to,
this was a while ago,
but I'm like,
okay,
now I'm starting to get it here.
Like people have ethical concerns about
where their meat comes from.
Yeah.
My friend Jake shields,
he's a go fight in the UFC and he's a
worldclass Jujitsu black belt.
He's been a vegetarian his whole life.
But he said he would eat meat that was
hunted.
Yeah.
He was like,
cause that's,
you know,
there's no ethical,
it adds up in his head for him.
Right.
Like the answers his questions and
sonically,
but that's exactly it.
I've had some awesome conversations
with,
with people that were not hunters that,
um,
asked great questions.
You know,
way better than conversations I've had
with guys that call themselves hunters
at times.
Some,
yeah.
I mean this again,
it's the problem with human beings,
right?
It's,
there's,
there's certain people that just aren't
thinking that much and that,
and then there's certain,
there's certain parts of the hunting
culture that are really a boring.
They,
they,
there's,
there's people that think it's funny or
fun to shoot as many animals as they can
and they don't,
they don't have any consideration to,
you know,
that this life has been taken so that
your life can be nurtured or get
nutrition from this animal.
And they're not thinking of it in terms
of this cycle of life.
They're just thinking of in terms of,
you know,
it's,
it's like the worst aspects that you get
like in a movie about hunting.
And for me like doing it,
going to the Arctic,
um,
I bring that up often because it's my
favorite place.
But once you realize the Arctic your
favorite place,
I just,
uh,
just so wide open and um,
you know,
you have,
northern lights at night if you're,
if you're locking massive moose and
Caribou,
like watching Caribou migrate and
Grizzly bears eating blueberries.
And you know,
I've been,
I spent so much time with wolves up in
these areas and,
and,
and really engaging with the wolves and
stuff and just,
it's just always fed these experiences
to me.
And that's what really started to mean.
That's what really mattered the most to
me was being in these areas,
taking a deep breath,
being super present,
being super aware and seeing all of
these different things that were filling
my soul.
Right?
True soul food wall.
I was hunting and Moose are wall.
I was hunting and Caribou and then maybe
being successful on a moose or Caribou
in and skinning it out and,
and feeling the weight on my back.
So I'm getting it back to camp.
And the northern lights or overhead or
the,
if they're not out,
the stars are out and I'm hearing wolves
howling.
And I,
you know,
I,
uh,
I lived with a pack of wolves one summer
in Alaska when I was up there doing
research.
And so like all of these with a pack of
wolves.
So I just do that.
Um,
I was,
uh,
I was doing research for the US fish and
wildlife service and a,
I ran a research campa genetics camp for
the,
from June through September,
may through September or whatever.
I did it five years in a row and,
and one year a pack of wolves moved into
my research camp and,
oh,
it was,
whoa.
I mean,
I went fly fishing one night and I was
standing on the bank of a river casting
and it was an eerie little river that I
was on is pretty quiet,
but it had a good flow.
And we were,
I was waiting for salmon to come up and
I was fly fishing for grayling.
And,
uh,
it just kind of had this eerie feeling.
I was by myself and I was just had this
eerie feeling that it's being watched.
And,
and I happened to look behind me.
And there's a big alder thicket,
right?
These,
these,
these bushes that are probably 10 to 12
feet high,
have green leaves on them in these
twisted,
gnarly,
almost like a,
you know,
boo Radley type tree,
like gnarly branches.
And I was,
I was just staring in,
in,
in the alders and there's grizzly bears
where I was.
So I was just trying to mind my,
and I'm,
you know,
I'm walking on wolf and Grizzly bear
attracts I'm fishing.
So I was just staring back in the
dollars.
And um,
it was,
it was like a movie.
So my,
my eyes were starting to truncate down
on the leaves and then all of a sudden
it came to all this little opening.
I could see a wolf's face staring at me
through the olders.
And,
and she was probably 10 yards away,
something like that.
And so I saw her and when I looked at
her,
she was just staring at me and I just
looked back at her and I,
and I just said,
hey,
you know,
I just said hey,
I said,
hey mom,
what's going on?
And I just kept fishing because I wanted
her to know that I knew and I turned my
back on her.
I kept fishing.
Well Lo and behold,
she comes out on the sandbar with me and
she starts walking down behind me.
And it was funny cause if I didn't make
eye contact she was totally chill.
But if I made eye contact,
she would snarl at me.
She raised her lips up and give a little
seated girl
and so she was standing.
Now she's probably three feet behind me.
What?
Yeah.
And so she's,
she's right there.
She's literally right there.
And so I'm just like,
hey mom,
what's going on?
Just cast my flyer on.
And like when I'm not looking at her,
she's kind of trying to check me out.
She's doing the whole nose extension,
getting a with,
so she moves off,
she moves off down that she moves off
down to have a gun on you.
I did have a 12 gauge at that time.
I left 12 gauge slug gun.
Um,
but I've rarely took that thing with me.
But I got in trouble actually from one
of my bosses because one of the other
biologists told my boss is like never,
he never carries the gun and we're
supposed to carry a gun everywhere we
go.
And so I'm just like,
whatever.
But um,
so she laughed and I'm worried that she
was gonna attack,
you know,
now she gets it so close.
That seems weird.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
she was just checking me out.
She's just checking me out.
And that's,
that's,
that's how I was reading into it anyway.
Just by the way you were talking to her
that she realized that you weren't even
interested in being a threat and she was
confident that she can get the fuck away
from you.
That's a good question.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
And not a feet.
Yeah,
that's this.
That's one,
two,
three.
Yeah,
maybe even two and a half feet.
Like she was right behind me.
You could touch her.
Oh,
it gets much better.
It gets much better.
I end up spending a whole summer with
her and all the other animals in the,
in the pack.
So the next day I hear her howell down
the river.
So I'm just messing around.
So I hold back to her.
She holds back to me instantly.
I hobbled back to her.
All of a sudden I see her.
She's now standing exactly where I was
standing the night before.
It's all true story.
She's sitting on her butt sitting
upright,
like you would see a German shepard
sitting staring at me.
So I give her just a little coy,
little Rah Rah Rah Rah.
She lays down,
she maintains eye contact with me and
then she just sitting there staring at
me and then she sits up again and I will
again,
just a little one.
She lays down again.
She just maintaining eye contact.
Then she leaves that night.
So that area,
the Tundra that I was on,
um,
is greatly impacted by even human foot
traffic.
So you have to be really careful where
you step because you know,
your footprint will be there for a long
time.
So we'd walk on these little planks that
we made out of two by fours.
I would sit up on logs that were,
you know,
that we put and placed in,
in and put a place night 10 rice slapped
and I had a genetics 10 where I did all
my stuff.
Then I had to cook 10 things like that.
And so,
but right in front of my tent I had this
little platform where I would get
dressed in the morning cause I would,
I would literally live for five and a
half months in a little two and a half
person pup tent.
And so I get out in the morning and get
dressed on this little piece of wood and
then I'd walk to breakfast or whatever
or to the river in the middle of the
night that Alpha male was sitting on my
little platform and he how old it right
outside my tent.
And I sat up and I grabbed my gun and I
was just sitting there and he woke me up
from a dead sleep and I was just sitting
there panting with my gun and I was
looking all around and I didn't know
what it was.
Then I heard something and I kind of
peeked out and I saw that it was just
big male.
I was,
I got,
okay,
it's just not just a wolf,
but like,
you know,
he's not going to bother me at all.
And so I hung my gun back up and I just
aren't set my gun back down and I just
laid back down.
But those two instances just started
each day.
Um,
the next day I come out and I'm walking
to the genetics tent and I see him,
he's 20 yards away and he's paralleling
me on this plank and I go into the cook
tent and then I'm kind of like peeking
out the little corners,
you know,
like I want to,
I,
cause I don't know what they're doing.
I don't want to walk out and get
attacked or,
and,
and I,
I don't think that they have no body
language of hunting whatsoever.
And so what is their body language of
curiosity?
Curiosity.
Yeah.
And um,
I hate to,
um,
anthropomorphize.
Yeah.
But it was just like,
it was just like that movie never cry
wolf.
That's exactly how the wolves were
engaged with that movie.
Just about a researcher,
a book by Farley Mowat of a researcher
that went up to the Canadian government
had,
they were thinking that wolves were
decimating these caribou herds.
And so they sent this biologists out
there to research the wolves to see how
many care were they were killing in the,
basically what the biologists found out
was that the wolves weren't in killing
any Caribou zero Caribou.
They were killing redback voles and they
were fishing.
And they're doing other ways.
They're eating small animals,
which is basically a very large part.
What wolves do.
The very small animals and occasionally
killed Caribou,
occasionally kill Moose,
things like that in certain areas there,
um,
they can be really hardcore predators
and other areas that eat a lot of mice.
And so,
um,
but that's how these wolves are engaging
with the actor in this movie.
And you know,
they were kind of inquisitive.
They're coming around and,
and so these,
these wolves,
they were just always present.
Like even I would go hiking just to get
some exercise and literally three or
four of them would go with me and they'd
hang back like 50,
60 yards behind me.
But I had high for like 10 miles.
And then they do the whole thing with me
and returned back to camp with me.
And then it started to really grow,
um,
cause we have this research gear that's
in the river so that we can count
speciate and sample the salmon as they
swim through to go spawn.
But after the salmon spawn,
they all die,
right?
And so they would spawn die and they'd
come back and they'd wash up on my gear.
And so I'd have all these,
that's why the wolves were there.
They wanted to eat the dead fish that
were coming back down.
And so as I started toss fish off on the
banks of the river,
usually I would just toss them back into
the river.
But I tossed him on the banks of fresher
fish and a,
the wolves started eating them.
And then our relationship just kept
growing and growing and growing and
growing.
And,
and then I'm spending like three and a
half months with them.
Did you think while you were doing this,
this is probably how human beings and
wolves developed this relationship?
A hundred percent a hundred percent a
hundred percent and I actually,
I feel bad saying this and I hope I
don't offend anybody,
but I was working with two in you at
guys to ask them,
oh guys.
And they want him to shoot all these
wolves.
I kind of lied to him.
And I just
said,
man,
like,
have you ever seen wolves behave like
this?
And they said no.
And I said,
well,
you know,
some of your guys' beliefs,
fall that your ancestors move on into
the animal kingdom.
Right?
And they're like,
yeah.
And I said,
well,
is there a chance that some of these
wolves could be some of your ancestors?
You know,
and I know that it's not true.
At least I think,
I know that's not true,
but they're like,
yeah,
yeah.
So I just was trying to convince these
guys cause they wanted to blast these
things.
And so I just convinced him not to shoot
the wolves and I feel like an asshole
singing.
Why do you feel like an asshole saying
that?
I don't know.
I just didn't want them to shoot the
wolves.
So I just kind of,
probably a good way to rationalize.
I steered them down a path of,
of where their minds may have gone
anyway.
Yeah.
And so,
but I,
I spend time with those wolves and I've
had,
um,
you know,
in the,
uh,
in the idea of management,
like when we're in,
in,
in the short that Jamie was just playing
who we are,
that we played.
You can see some wolves in there.
And a few years ago I got surrounded by
a pack of wolves in the Arctic with the
crew and it films really beautifully.
And it was,
and it was one of the most remarkable
engagements I've ever had in the
wilderness.
Um,
and they were definitely,
their body language was definitely
looking at us as though are we food?
Right?
So this,
that was one of them,
but we had like six or seven wolves come
in behind us.
So this wolf would be in front of us,
two or three others would be behind
this,
but you can see they're not attacking
us.
They're not even hunting us.
But you can just see,
like,
they're wondering,
you know,
is there,
is there a play here?
Right?
Is there,
is there a play here?
And,
and,
um,
and I,
and I mean there's,
I'm not being a tough guy.
There wasn't an ounce that I didn't have
a,
not a fiber of my body was afraid at any
point.
And there's probably six,
seven molds around us within 10 yards
all and they're communicating,
they're doing this little like,
ah.
So they're talking to each other and
then they just moved off and it turns
out that the w the Moose that I was
stalking,
I think they were stocking too,
cause there was a big bowl that was
bedded and if they weren't stocking him,
cause I think they would have had their
hands full with him for that.
If they weren't stocking him then they
were just moving in that general
direction in a,
they were for sure hunting.
And I've just,
I've always had a tremendous respect for
them and I've always spent,
I've just,
I've always had time with them.
I've always had time.
And then I've always been,
I've had wolf tags in my pocket before.
You know,
this kind of falls under the same idea
of conservation.
Like these walls right here.
Right.
I had a wolf tag in my pocket.
I had my bowl.
I could've arrowed any of these wolves,
easily.
Multiples of them probably.
Um,
but I didn't want to kill a wolf here
because I,
you know,
they know when another wolf has gone
right.
The,
the pack knows.
And so that,
that weighs on me a little bit.
That's me.
We're so,
why,
right?
Like,
why kill him?
Like what is there too many of them?
This is a real issue.
Let's see.
That was the thing for me is like I
didn't have,
I didn't do my homework for this area,
so I was just like,
I dunno if there's a lot of wolves.
I don't under the little wolves,
I'm not going to kill the wolf.
I've no interest in killing wolf.
I get a wolf tag with my stuff.
Rinella was telling me that there was a,
one of the explorers that traveled the
West during the Lewis and Clark days,
his favorite meal was wolf.
Hmm.
And that wolf was literally his favorite
thing to eat.
I've never eaten it.
Yeah.
I would have a real hard time.
I just couldn't,
there are too much like dogs there.
I think there's some sort of a genetic
memory that we have of our relationship
with wolves.
They've,
I mean,
they've become dogs and they've become
our,
you know,
our companions and they become a part of
our community.
It just wasn't,
um,
you know,
it wasn't for me.
And when the pilot picked me up,
he asked me if I'd seen any wolves and I
said,
yeah,
we saw a lot of wolves and how he's like
all there now,
you know,
he's not,
I'm not telling you is running surveys
here,
but he's like,
yeah,
there's a lot of wolves here.
There's a lot of predation on,
on Moose here.
So we're trying to,
we're trying to really cut the wolves
down here.
But I,
and I saw a lot of wolves,
but I also saw a ton of Moose and I saw
a ton of cows and I saw lots of calves
and lots of big bowls.
So everything seemed to be functioning
in that area.
And I also saw a ton of,
um,
back vols right.
They look like mice with little short
tails.
And I know where there's a lot of red
back vols I know the wolves do extremely
well eating them.
And so you see these little tunnels
right in the Tundra and stuff.
And,
um,
I think wolves eat a lot smaller of prey
than people think on average.
Right.
We see sensational things of small dogs
or,
or wolves.
And we filmed,
I don't know if,
did you see the Dingo Hunt that we
filmed in Australia?
No.
Oh my God.
And I was wondering a Dingo Hunt?
Nope.
We were hunting buffalo and um,
while we were hunting Buffalo Dingo has
just exploded from the bush and the
dingoes.
We're pack hunting the Asiatic water
buffaloes.
Nobody's ever seen it before.
Nobody's ever filmed it before.
We had the Dingo institute call us
immediately from Australia.
We had Dingo,
small,
tiny dude.
So we filmed all that is not straight.
It's literally never been filmed before
to our knowledge.
Uh,
everyone that we talked to that is Dingo
researchers,
they want to know exactly where this was
because I'd never seen this behavior and
see this behavior right here,
that was actually coming in to hunt Das.
But you can see the whole crew sat down.
Everybody was totally committed.
They're trying to kill that calf right
there.
And still that calf is monstrous,
right?
So there's four or five,
six on there.
And then they chase,
they stampede the whole herd directly
right into us.
That's what you're seeing right here.
And that the heard actually comes to
like 15 feet before they split around
us.
We're all sitting on our butts and then
the dingoes actually turn their
attention to us and they come in around
us.
And you,
cause you can see us instantly looking
at us as a,
we're a meal,
but like wolves,
like grizzly bears,
like black bears,
very quickly they look at you and they
got,
yeah,
this is not going to work out for me.
Yeah.
They don't want to die.
You know what I mean?
So like,
yeah,
nobody had ever seen die.
Why the fuck are they going after water
bottle?
Terrible idea.
But obviously there,
I dunno if this group has done this
before.
Well they must've ride.
The must have been successful on the
calf,
you know,
and the idea is that they're going to
chase him and wear him out and that one
of the cavs going to be separated.
They're going to take it down.
Yeah.
But they're like 35 pounds.
That's so crazy.
It's such a small animal.
And these calves,
even the calves are probably like a
hundred pounds
bigger.
Yeah.
Maybe even 200.
That Guy Looks Australia is fuck the
other guy.
Yeah,
he's barefoot and everything.
I might,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
I got my hat.
So yeah.
So just all these instances like this,
literally,
I hate to,
but this why I hunt like that stuff.
I'm not,
I'm probably not going on a photo safari
ever in my entire life.
I'm not climbing Mount Everest unless
there's something at the top that I'm
need.
It's just not men.
My DNA is not who I am,
but,
but going out to,
um,
kill a water buffalo in Australia
because they're not only are they
overpopulated,
they're absolutely decimating the
country and they're not supposed to be
there.
No,
I mean,
he killed them all.
You could snap your fingers right now,
kill every buffalo in on the continent
of Australia and you'd be doing nothing
but helping that place.
Right.
And so,
um,
those are the kinds of engagements that
I love,
right.
Going there and seeing these things,
you're not going to see him unless
you're there and you're not gonna see
him unless you're there for very long
time.
Yeah.
Being in the woods and seeing wildlife
in its wild environment is a crazy
experience.
I was telling my friend Colton,
he's a guide in Utah and I was saying,
you guys should have a thing for people
that have zero desire to hunt and let
them,
like take them,
put them in full cammo and have them
creep through the woods during the Rut
and watch these elk scream at each other
and communicate and just,
just to be around them is amazing.
It's a,
it's an amazing cause then to know that
these things have done this for
thousands,
if not millions of years.
I mean they've found whitetail deer
skulls in Florida that have been age to
over a million years.
So they know that they've been in that
form and likely elk as well in that form
for a fucking million,
maybe even more years.
These things.
This is what they've done.
They've done it forever.
And to be around them when they don't
know you're there.
Um,
we did this,
a film for underarmor,
me and a Cam Haynes,
and we went elk hunting and Utah and we,
we were in this,
uh,
this wooded area watching these elk that
were in this meadow by a stream.
And we sat there waiting for a shot
opportunity for like,
like an hour or so watching them.
They had no idea we were there.
And you know,
some of them were 15,
20 yards.
Well,
yeah.
And I was like,
this is the cra,
it just to be around them when they
don't know you're there.
It's so amazing.
Yeah.
Wash and breathe.
Washington week.
We did it last year with,
um,
uh,
men's health and article on us.
And um,
so we took,
it was trippy.
Like I'm talking to the art director at
men's hall.
She's in downtown Manhattan.
They have no idea what life is about.
So she's like,
he had Donnie.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
have you and your crew.
So there's three in my crew and then
we're going to have a photographer,
photographers assistant,
and then we'll have the writer with you.
Well good luck.
So I'm just like,
all right.
So I'm stocking bull elk and I've never
elk hunted before,
so I have no idea what I'm doing other
than what I've read about.
And so I'm stocking these bowls with six
people.
And they asked me like,
Hey,
do we have to wear camouflage that no,
you don't have to wear camouflage.
And they said,
well what is there anything we shouldn't
wear?
And I said,
just try not to wear anything with a
really bright start colors and try not
to wear any bright yellows.
Cause that's the spectrum.
That elk scene and the photographer,
photographer assistant shows off with
just,
I mean like canary,
yellow pants,
skinny jeans.
And I'm like eight from Ohi.
Where's a little high that's here,
right in southern California.
Yeah.
So they're from Ohio.
And um,
but it was wicked cause we snuck up to
eight.
We got to 18 yards from the six by six,
all of us,
six of us,
18 yards from the six by six.
And what was crazy is there staring at
the six by six,
like all of their jaws are on the
ground,
but I'm staring at them because I really
don't care about the six by six.
He's too young.
I'm not going to shoot him.
But I loved,
I was addicted to their reactions and
they're just like,
and the elk Wa actually,
so we're staring at them,
the elk staring at these guys.
I'm staring at them.
I'm just like taking this on.
I'm like,
this is pretty Rad.
Nevada Shell Creek range in Nevada.
Um,
and so we're sending,
all of a sudden the elk looks to its
left really sharply.
And so I look over and there's a coyote
10 yards from us staring at the ELAC.
And then all these guys are seeing the
Chi out there,
seeing the ELAC.
And then everything runs away.
And I turn around and look at these guys
and they're just like,
oh,
like,
um,
the one photographer,
he's like,
that was a literal monster.
And it was like a three year old,
six by six and four year old,
66 and he's like that thing.
And like I just shut up and I'm just
living in these guys and they're just
Jay and now two of the three of them on
a hunt,
they'd never hunt in their lives.
Now that writer,
writer Michael Easter,
he really wants to hunt and he's
actually going to go on another hunt
with me I think.
And next year I'm going to spend like 40
days in the Yukon territories,
just walking from one end to this
concession that a friend of mine has
like four and a half million acres.
We're going to try to walk from one half
Kinda to the other half if you will,
in hunting our way through just kind of
doing journal,
hunt film,
the whole thing.
Beautifully tried to and tell a story
and he wants to go along and write a
book about the experience.
Yeah.
And so,
but that's the thing.
It's like all these guys,
like they just,
just to see their look,
seeing this bull elk right there and
like in,
they're watching him and he,
he put on quite a show.
He didn't bugle.
I really wish you would have,
although they heard bugles cause we
camped at 12,000 feet.
I made them hike all the way up to the
top.
I'm like man,
if we're camping cabin at the tippity
top,
I want you guys to like just experience.
And so bugles would echo out at night
around the canyon but they watched him
eat and he,
he made a rob and just,
you know,
mess this trip with his antlers and they
just there.
It was wicked great experience.
But I agree with you.
I think people like,
let's put some camouflage or hell where
yellow pants,
yellow where yellow skinny jeans if you
want.
And you're flat bill hat from Ohi and
let's go sneak up on l fuck flat bill
hats.
I'm saying it.
Yup.
No,
I'm sorry Jim.
Yup,
just kid.
This has a small curvature.
Just a small,
small curvature.
No,
he's,
he's been on a cavaliers tear over the
last few days.
All sorts of different hats on.
Um,
the,
just,
I think that,
uh,
what I was saying to these guys is like,
you would,
without even having to have a tag,
like you guys could guide these people
and it wouldn't be a dent and the
resources,
it wouldn't diminish the population.
No,
but it would,
it would be,
it's an educational experience and just,
there's ripples that come from that are
those people are going to go back and
tell other people about it.
And it's one thing to go to the zoo,
but you go to the zoo.
It's the most unnatural environment,
the world where animals are looking you
right in the eye and they're not
freaking out that that has nothing to do
with what you're talking about.
Those two things you can see,
and I'll cut at the zoo,
but you can't watch an elk.
The elk is not an alk.
It's a,
it's a farm animal.
It's just not the same.
When you see one in the wild and
they're,
their noses are flaring and they're
smelling the air.
And they're,
their ears are twitching left and right.
It's scanning for noises and you realize
like,
wow,
this thing is out there fucking earning,
hustling,
you know,
eating grass,
trying to stay alive.
And if,
if it gets to,
you know,
like that elk that I have out there was
nine years old,
a nine year old animal that's out there
surviving against mountain lions and
bears and just figuring out a way to get
through and keep surviving,
get through those winters,
make it to spring,
keep going,
keep going.
I mean that is uh,
it's,
it's an amazing animal.
Has a story.
The thing has a story and you,
and if you sit down,
you know,
I'm sure you were sad when you kill
them,
but you sit down and,
and I'm sure you were euphoric as hell
that your plan finally worked because
you've watched it fail 2000 times.
So you sit there with your kind of holy
crap moment of this actually happened
and he's actually dead now.
And you know,
you have the sorrow of taking an
animal's life,
but then you sit there and you have any
perspective at all.
You think about those nine years,
just like you just did you think like
any minute of those nine years and he'd
say much like sheep,
you know,
or like,
um,
your water buffalo back here,
like this is horn,
right?
So they don't lose it every year that
the l cast their antlers off every year
and grow new ones,
which is,
I think it's fastest growing biological
substance known to man.
Right.
So crazy.
But,
but these things have horn,
so it's made out of like fingernail.
So you literally can sit there with your
buffalo and track your fingernail or a
big horn sheep are dall sheep and drag
your finger nail through these little
cracks and you see the splits and cracks
and you're like,
you know,
what was a bad winter and what was a
great spring?
And when did the wolves chase you?
And,
um,
when did you almost lose your life in a
fight?
And when like I wish,
you know,
I wish we could kind of hold on to these
things and kind of go through a little
montage of what to sing live through,
you know?
But that's the only thing we can do is
insert ourselves into the wilderness for
a short amount of time or as much time
as we can afford and,
and,
and
convince ourselves that that's where we
still live.
Yeah,
I mean that just
the relationship that we have with
nature I think is,
it's taken such a bizarre turn because
of cities.
I think that what we've done also in our
relationship with animals,
by putting them in these little animal
prisons that we call zoos and having
people go and stare at them and some
very unnatural way,
we've really distorted the majesty of
wildlife and nature.
And the only,
in my opinion,
the only real way to appreciate what an,
what an animal is,
is to see an animal in the wild to see
it in its habitat.
And until that happens,
until you do that,
you really,
you could see a,
you know,
a giraffe at the zoo and they're pretty
majestic.
They're really crazy.
And they're one of the weirdest animals
too because they let little kids feed
them.
I mean,
they're so confident in their behavior.
Ms. I had a a bit about it in my act and
that,
like you say that animals don't belong
in the zoo.
I'm like,
I,
I agree with you except for giraffes.
Xerox don't seem to have any fucking
problem with the zoo.
They love it.
Yeah.
My joke was that they're like another
day with no lions and they're just
wandering around having a great old
time.
They,
I mean they,
they're so confident that like when my
daughter was two,
we brought her to the zoo and they'll
let a two year old hold a piece of
lettuce up for a giraffe.
They just fucking,
no.
Yeah.
But if you saw a g,
like I said,
the first time I ever saw him,
I was from my friend Mike Hawk Ridge and
my friend Ben O'brian,
the first time I ever saw a moose in the
wild,
we pulled the car over and it was like
that scene in Jurassic Park when Jeff
Goldbloom sticks his head out of the
jeep and he's like,
wow.
Like you see one in the wild,
you realize how big they really are.
And this thing was just walking through
this open field in the woods and we were
like,
Holy Shit.
Look at the size of that thing.
Filmmaker killed by Giraffe by working
in South Africa.
Oh yeah.
He got headbutted,
right?
Yeah.
That's how they do it.
Oh yeah.
They,
they,
they use their head like a whip.
We showed a film of these two battling
these two bulls,
slam each other with their heads.
It's fucking crazy.
Total.
Yeah.
As is anything that lives out there.
That's a way to go.
Huh?
Get killed by a giraffe.
You didn't even see it.
He was looking through the camera.
Oh,
no,
no.
Oh yeah.
He still thinks she's looking through a
camera right now.
He probably is some of the dimension.
Yeah.
It's like what happened?
Oh,
everyone's gone.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That had to be lights out and that's
back to the grizzly bear hunting thing.
That's it.
That's the unfortunate thing,
right?
It's all those people that closed down
hunting.
They never even,
they all,
I would,
I would venture a guess that anyone that
voted on that ballot has never seen a
bear or Bennett
grizzly bear territory or participated
at all in understanding how that
ecosystem works isn't in a very small
percentage of people.
It was a very small number of people and
they got the information from an email
list.
Right.
I think the people,
I think it was less than 3000 people.
Yeah,
something really crazy.
Which heil of misinformation and a and
rumor.
Well it's also if you talk to the actual
wildlife biologists and maybe even more
importantly the people that are in the
field on a daily basis,
like there is no pop,
no problem with the grizzly bear
population in British Columbia.
In fact,
it's thriving and it's a giant animal
that eats a lot of meat and it's out
there,
taken out a lot of calves right now as
we speak,
and now that they can't hunt them,
they're very likely to have a situation
where they're going to have to hire
people to shoot problem bears.
Absolutely.
The first eco tour that goes down where
a a boat full or a bus full or a hiking
group watches a boar kill and eat
triplets,
kill and eat three football or
watermelon sized cubs and rip them to
shreds and eat them while they're
bawling and trying to get to their mom
and then have him killed her mom.
Once that goes down and be like,
okay,
I think we might have a couple too many
barriers here,
so now we're again,
but that happens every day even in a
great,
not everyday but it happens often even
in a good population but now that
they've shut down any killing
whatsoever,
these things have no predators other
from old bores that become giant bullies
on the block.
Yeah.
What are they going to do about that?
Because apparently there is some sort of
a movement to try to educate people and
get them to understand what they've done
by making this hunt illegal.
But what I would like to see is people
also be educated on the fact like what
you said,
that these animals are actually edible
and that instead,
maybe the part of the problem is the
fact that these people are just taking
the head in the hide and leaving behind
the meat.
And if you were responsible for not just
taking the meat but showing that you're
consuming it and then teaching these
people how to cook it and then how to
prepare it and,
and make them realize like you should be
using this thing is in its entirety as a
resource.
And don't just think about it as this
fucking rug or this,
you know,
skull that you're going to have on your
wall.
And that's the problem.
I think that's the problem.
I don't know.
But I think that's the problem because
if people,
and some people do think this,
I get letters like this all the time
where people say,
let me get this straight.
So,
and it always happens after we posted a
picture of me with an animal in my
backpack,
elk,
antlers or whatever.
They're like,
Oh yup,
I can see it.
You know how many meet in that backpack?
And I tell him like,
look,
my first four backpack loads were meat.
I'm taking the head out last.
That's how we do it.
The head goes out last because it's the
least of importance.
It holds the,
the least importance.
And so the hide in the head go out last.
So if you take a picture of a backpack
full of meat,
it looks like a backpack,
cause the meats inside.
So it looks like you're wearing a
backpack.
So,
and we purposefully did one last year in
Nevada.
You can see
the elks hooves sticking out of the top
of the backpack.
So people realize like,
we are moving quarters and we publish
these photos.
But so people will Ryan and say,
seat,
let me get this straight.
You kill the deer.
You take its life,
you take it's hide.
And he'd take his antlers and you just
take it home in mountain and you leave
everything else to rot and said,
no,
no.
But it says that it's,
they,
they're ignorant.
They're not paying any attention.
Well the there whatsoever.
That's willful ignorance because you
could find that out in,
first of all,
everyone knows that deer's delicious
deer,
venison and elk in particular.
It's delicious meat.
The fact that you would even consider
leaving that behind,
it's crazy.
Nobody does that.
I've never heard of anybody doing that.
I know I've heard of it,
but I've heard a lot of fear in elk.
Not,
not in,
not in reality.
I've just heard of it.
Right.
I've heard people saying,
oh yeah,
it's what they used to do.
It's what they did and you know,
I couldn't even imagine that as a
scenario in,
in today's Day.
I mean,
the meat is so good.
I've had people at my house before,
they've never eaten elk and I've cooked
it for him.
They're like,
Holy Shit.
Because it has a,
there's a feeling you get from eating it
too.
It almost like his energy in it.
I get charges you up.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's such a potent protein and so
delicious.
I said that with leave that behind me.
That should be a crime.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I if,
if,
if anything,
I've seen it go the other way.
I've seen hunters argue over their
share,
right?
Like if you're sharing an elk with a
friend or you went on a hunt and one you
kill.
Okay.
So like,
well how much do I get?
You know,
I've seen guys argue over that more than
anything.
And I sent,
I sent elk meat to a,
the writer of men's health,
um,
who's writing the article cause I ended
up killing the elk two days after he
left,
he had to go on another story and I
ended up killing you Alex.
So he's like,
Hey,
will you send me a box of meat so I can
try it?
Cause I feel like I was really a part of
this hunt and I did so.
And he's just like,
yeah,
he,
I mean he wrote about in the article but
it's in the last paragraph forever.
But he sent me a text message and he's
just like,
are you freaking kidding me?
This is the funniest thing I've ever
eaten in my life.
And he's like,
it's prepared correctly,
but you have to learn how to do that
too.
And he's,
you know,
he's seared everything.
He talked to us and we told you,
you want to keep it like really medium
rare and just,
he just loved it.
He loved it.
And,
and uh,
and he talked about like all those days
that he hiked with us in the mountains,
you know,
he remarked that he could taste that in
the flesh.
Right.
He felt that he felt that connection.
Now he's like big time wants to,
wants to start hunting first food.
Yeah.
I always tell people,
if you really want to start hunting,
you really want to do it.
It's so difficult to get started.
It's so difficult to even find the
resources to take the first steps.
Like what do you do?
And people that say,
I want to bow hunt.
I'm like,
listen man,
first of all,
you need to learn how to shoot a bow.
And second of all,
by saying that you want to bow hunt,
what you're saying to me is I want to
practice 300 days a year with my bow.
I want to really learn archery.
I want to learn the proper form.
I want to learn mental control.
I want to learn the ability to say,
to keep your mind
in,
in the moment while you're under extreme
anxiety and facing an animal,
to understand how to range an animal,
how to,
what's the proper yardage,
where's the proper shot placement?
You're talking about a lifestyle.
You're talking about literally changing
your life.
This is not,
don't say I want to go bow hunting.
Like I want to go deep sea fishing on a
charter.
They put the fee,
the bait on the hook,
drop it in,
and I just really the the,
the fish,
that's,
that's possible.
Yeah.
That's saying I want to go bow hunting.
Like,
you know,
they see you do it and they go,
oh,
you bow hunt.
Yup.
Okay.
But I'm crazy and I've been obsessed
with this shit for years and I practice
every day and you go to my backyard,
I've got fucking rubber elk sitting on a
hillside and I shoot at him every day
before I do anything.
So how much do you want to do it?
Yeah.
How much do you really want to do it?
Because you first have to come on
archer.
Yes.
Then you have to learn something about
hunting and now you have to actually get
out of your truck and take a bunch of
steps into the Wilderness and hope you
can even just get back to your truck,
let alone finding an animal,
illegal animal sneaking into within
archery range,
killing him quickly.
Dismembering them,
getting them.
I mean,
it's gotta be in shape.
The other thing that freaked me out when
I first went hunting,
I was in shape as far as like Jujitsu,
martial art,
Shay,
but fucking hiking with a backpack on
and altitude and you're going up and
down and up and down.
It's like an hours a day like,
oh,
okay,
you gotta be conditioned for this shit.
Yeah.
I think if you want to,
I mean,
I think the way to do it if somebody
really wants to is really wild pigs,
wild pigs with a gun is probably the
first way you should do it because I
think first of all,
it has to be done.
This is something that's imperative.
You're,
you're talking about can't be done
enough.
It can't be done enough.
Again,
you could go no wild pigs starting now
and it would be a great,
it'd be a great service.
It'd be a great service except for
people enjoy wild pig meat and hunting
because it's awesome.
Yeah,
I mean it's an awesome way to get
started too.
You go wild pig hunting,
you're,
you're doing good for the environment.
This is an invasive species that
devastates ground nesting birds,
all sorts of plant species and,
and if you're dealing with agriculture
like wow,
you mean then it's really,
you're talking about a massive financial
burden on farmers,
but with a rifle,
that's the way to do it because the
right,
it's so much easier if you have a rifle
rest and someone can take you to a
range.
The learning curve is so much shorter
than when the bow.
Yeah,
absolutely.
100% and that's a great,
that's a great first animal.
The only other thing that I would maybe
say if,
if somebody could share with you is to
share a duck blind or something along
those lines.
Because sometimes it's difficult to wrap
your head around killing a large animal
first.
It might help to kill.
As odd as that sounds,
we're more comfortable with killing
pheasants or grouse or docs or something
like that.
But,
um,
that's also a very tricky shot.
And you know,
there's,
and there's safety there because a
number of people have guns and not
everyone's paying attention.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
Have you been the one?
I,
I haven't,
uh,
I,
I've done it two years in a row now
where we hunt axis deer in Lanai and
it's another one of those things that
has to be done.
There's something around 3000 people on
the island and more than 20,000 access
deer.
And it's a very small island and it's
fucking bananas.
I mean,
we were coming home from,
uh,
w w we got super lucky on the first
night,
the first night a hunting we got out of
the truck.
We set up a target to see if the bows
were in tune shot one arrow at a target
and a Alec.
The guy that I was with went,
fuck,
there's a buck about 200 yards.
Look right there.
And we're like,
Holy Shit.
We kicked off our shoes,
stocked in on him and I killed them
within 15 minutes,
which is nuts because what the next four
days without killing anything,
and I finally got another one on the
last day,
but you can shoot as many as 12 day.
And then they want to get rid of all of
course eating themselves up a house in a
home.
Right?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
The numbers,
the numbers are crazy,
but it's also crazy how tuned in these
things are.
And then they evolved to escape tigers.
Oh yeah,
they're,
they're from India.
They are fucking switched on.
They're like a whitetail deer on
steroids and meth.
I mean,
they're like,
what?
What's up?
What's up your own?
And they're gone and they're so fast.
Man,
I've never seen an animal so fast.
So wicked.
Yeah.
But it's a good argument for hunting.
It's like,
well,
here's the,
here's the situation where the animals
are out there,
the population is fucked up.
There's no balance of life here.
This is not like this.
There's no balance here.
This is completely out of balance and
because of that they hire snipers.
I was just going to shake them.
Yeah.
I'm assuming they hiring guns to come in
at night and shoot them a night.
Scopes are exactly,
that's exactly what,
just to keep it in,
just to keep it somewhat in check.
But unless you want to let wolves loose
on this island and you know,
I don't know how else you're going to
fix that.
You want to put tigers there.
That's what's really supposed to be
catching them.
I actually studied tigers right out of
college in Bangladesh and Nepal and I
would see,
I would see access deer there and they
were,
I mean the jungle there.
That was real.
So like they,
that's why they're looking at
everything,
right?
Because you look at a tiger and a zoo
and you're like,
there's no way that thing can hide,
but then you go to the jungle and
everything is green.
Except for all the palms that die turned
bright orange and they all have really
long sharp,
uh,
frons that look like a tiger stripes.
He sees little blotches of orange and
black all disappearing into the green
and so,
but we would see the deer and the deer
would know,
like when we were going into an area to,
to either,
we had a cat that was radio collared,
are going in to look at a particular
piece of habitat.
The deer were just like on pins and
needles.
Like we'd get him remotely close and you
could see him.
We're dealing a lot with islands and
you'd
see him leaving the island on the other
side,
like they'd be ditching the swim to the
next island.
Wow.
Very aware.
They're extremely aware.
How crazy is it that somehow or another
the tiger evolve to develop those
stripes that looked like the colors in
nature?
Like what is the mechanism?
Phenotypical representation.
Yes.
He's all like,
this is from,
I don't know where this picture was
taken,
but this reminds me of like in Nepal and
southern Nepal where I was the Royal
Chitwan National Forest.
They had this grass that grows like 20
feet tall and I mean just absolutely
disappear.
But how bizarre is it that this animal
somehow or another evolve this
camouflage?
Yeah.
It's so strange.
So strange that that's what's so
amazing,
you know,
so the evolution of it and that,
this idea of,
of phenotypical their physical
representation that their genetics is
just so fantastic.
What did you study in college while
biology?
Yeah,
cause I wanted to,
you know,
when I got started doing,
hunting and things like that,
I don't come from a hunting family.
So I just,
um,
when did you start hunting?
Oh,
as soon as I could,
like when I was,
um,
10,
11,
12,
I would force my dad.
Um,
he had a,
he had a couple of guns cause he just
had guns and he was a kid and he would,
he would go up and he'd go like deer
hunting once a year with a buddy of his
in Maine.
But you know,
I think they just drank beer and I don't
think that he,
like,
he never killed a deer.
I don't think they ever even deer on and
they just literally drive up getting a
cabin and their bodies and get hammered,
get hammered.
I think that was probably gay scenario,
right?
That's like when,
when I was in high school,
uh,
one of my friends from high school,
he did that.
He,
his,
uh,
his family would,
go deer hunting and his dad literally
never killed a deer.
I was like,
that is the dumbest Shit I've ever heard
in my life.
Your Dad spends all this time hunting in
the woods is never killed a d not
hunting.
Yeah.
David Able David.
So,
but yeah,
so my,
My,
my dad is a gift to me was,
uh,
my grandparents got him a subscription,
outdoor life books.
So He'd get all these at all of these
books that were painted by these gifted
authors.
One of them was named Jack O'Connor,
who's inspired my entire career,
but I'd read all these things and,
and so I just thought,
I want to spend time outside,
so might as well get a wildlife biology
degree and then do research and live
outside and things like that.
And it was odd.
As odd as it was when I was in college,
I was still hunting a lot and I had
family and friends sent me down and
they're like,
hey man,
you got to like buckle down on your
studies.
And I wasn't disagreeing with them,
but they're like,
you need to stop hunting.
Stop hunting so much.
And because I'd literally,
I'd go to the Arctic Caribou hunting by
myself and I'd come home and go to
classes and then I'd leave to go to
Alaska on a black bear hunt.
I'd come home and go to classes and I've
just save as much money as I could.
Didn't party,
didn't drink with any of my body's,
didn't,
you know,
didn't do anything lavish.
I just literally kept going on trips and
you know,
it's kind of basically what's led to my
career today.
But it was funny that I,
you know,
these kinds of things traveled in
parallel,
if you will.
When did you start making films and when
you did it,
did you make them with the intention of
trying to relay like what I was
explaining at the beginning of the
podcast that what you do best as you,
you as much as possible in an hour,
you're relaying the whole experience as
opposed to what you're going to get when
you see a hunting television show or
what,
especially what you're going to get when
you see honey in a movie.
So I,
we started in 2012 and uh,
I had some guys that approached me to
host a hunting TV show and I said,
why,
what's that going to look like?
And I said,
well,
we'll pay for your trips.
Um,
we'll get all your sponsors and stuff
lined up.
You'll be fully sponsored.
We'll split the sponsor dollars with
you.
We'll buy your air time x,
Y,
and z.
These guys were pretty wealthy.
I was like,
this sounds like the absolute dream to
me.
Um,
but I said,
I want to control how it's filmed,
where we go,
how we hunt and the gear that I use.
And they said 100%.
Well,
very quickly within like the first eight
days,
those things started to go out the
window.
They said,
we want you to go here and hunt with
this guy because he's super popular and
we want you to kill this animal.
We want you to wear this clothing.
And I was like,
no,
I never do any of this.
I'm not doing any of this.
So I said,
you know what,
you guys,
I appreciate the opportunity but I'm
going to walk away from this Gig.
And so I walked away from it.
Um,
and then I met,
ended up meeting up with kyle of whom
you met earlier is in your green room
right now.
And then another guy named William
Oltman,
who's our director of photography now at
CIC Manta.
And I met up with these guys and,
and through a series of weird
circumstances we ended up filming
together and we,
when we just started kind of going on
trips,
but when we started going on trips,
our intention was never to do a TV show.
Our intention was how can we tell a
story about what we're doing?
Because really what we're doing ends up
at having a really fantastic tale.
It doesn't have to be a huge tail.
It doesn't have to be moby Dick,
but there's a story whenever you're
going on these hunts.
And so we just decided to like,
how can we flesh this out?
So we just went on these trips,
we filmed them as beautifully as we
could.
We film them as completely as we could
write.
A lot of guys when they go on these
trips,
they'll film,
okay,
you arrived and now you're hunting and
then you kill an animal.
And they're just trying to like get a
little piece of when we would try and
film everything.
And then when we got done,
we started putting together our first
film and we thought,
okay,
we'll put together a film,
we'll see what the audience kind of
things and then we'll just play from
there and we'll just go from there and
see what happens.
And so I started writing the film,
writing the script,
every,
all the,
all the dialogue that was going to live
outside of what was already naturally
occurring on camera.
And I brought it into Kyle's office and
I was like,
yeah,
so read this.
And he picked up my notebook and he's
like,
dude,
I've never ever heard you talk like
this.
I've never,
it was I think probably a little bit
macho and a little bit sensational,
a little bit like,
um,
being actual delivered,
like delivering a line and trying to
convey something on film that wasn't me.
And he's like,
I've never,
it's like,
why don't you write like how you talk in
the office,
like when you're ranting and raving and
talking about wildlife and talking about
your experiences,
right.
Like that.
Like,
like paint a picture for us,
you know,
and um,
and answer some questions maybe that you
have of your own.
And so I started writing in that manner.
And then we released our first film in
2012 or 13.
Uh,
the river's divide,
uh,
was a story about a deer that I was
hunting for two years in North Dakota
and it just took off.
Yeah.
Watch that.
Steve,
Steve Watch named Steve.
Uh,
a friend of mine named him,
um,
because a friend of his,
uh,
whose name Steve said,
the fact that you named deer is idiotic
and completely stupid.
And my friend Jeff said,
great that the next year we find is new.
The name Steve.
It is a weird thing when you watch a lot
of these shows and people,
it's a piece of property in the trail
cameras and they have all these
different names to these deer.
I'm like,
that's where it gets real squirrely too.
It's not games.
And I do it too.
It's not good.
And we do,
and it's funny because we were actually
talking about this in the blind one day
and it's like,
we name things right?
[inaudible] if you have to,
if you have two sons,
you don't go yet.
There's,
um,
so there's my skinny boy,
the one that does okay in school and
here's the little fat one that we can't
keep pees on the fork with.
But,
uh,
these are my two kids here.
You know,
you're like,
no,
this is Bob and Jeff.
You know,
and,
and so like when were deer hunting with
these animals?
Like when you're on Lanai,
you don't have this opportunity,
but if you were there all year long,
you might be like,
Hey,
I saw the Bach with the crooked.
You might be like,
I saw crooked horn,
I saw him again tonight.
You know,
and then it rather than saying to your
wife,
your girlfriend,
your body's saying,
Hey,
I saw that,
you know,
that one block that I'm on it with the
Krogan instead of going down that road,
you start nicknaming all this stuff,
right?
People name their cars.
We named motorcycles.
We not,
I don't know,
whatever,
I'm going to shut up.
But you got this far in this hunting
journey and you just recently started
elk hunting.
Uh,
September is only so long.
And like I said,
I liked the Arctic,
so I would just always go moose hunting
and Caribou hunting and yeah,
but,
um,
no excuse whatsoever.
I,
I hunted,
um,
a few years ago in Colorado,
10 years ago,
15,
20 years ago,
I hunted cow elk.
I went on a cow elk hunt,
but I literally,
uh,
the hunt lasted three minutes.
Oh,
I hiked up in the pitch black.
I hiked up to like,
uh,
11,000 feet,
a second sun came up and there's a huge
cal look at 30 yards and I shot her and
I was like,
all right,
that's done.
And so I cut her up,
cleaned her up,
and I just had always went to Alaska
during September and not in the elk
mountains.
And finally it was just like,
I need to do this.
And it was awesome.
I had,
I had a good and bad experience,
um,
great experience with like the morning
that I killed was sensational.
Is misty rainy.
The Bulls were screaming,
everything was very wild where way back
in there,
it was really sensational,
really,
really impactful.
Um,
but up to that point,
the area that I was hunting,
the shell creek range in Nevada is they
only have a few tags there,
but when you get a tag,
everyone,
he,
um,
higher is basically all their family and
friends to come and help because it's
such a rare tag.
So there's 30 guys to every tag.
And so I saw four wheelers and side by
sides and there's complete and utter
intrusion,
negative intrusion by hunters into this
wilderness.
It's ridiculous.
And it needs to be stopped in my
opinion.
Like you should have to leave all your
motorized vehicles on pavement and going
to the mountains on foot.
That's my opinion.
But um,
this area that I was in,
they had something like 400 miles of,
um,
improved a two track roads that guys had
literally just like,
they see something over here they want
to get to,
they just start driving.
They're side by side right across the
sage brush and they just start beating
this stuff down.
And pretty soon there's a road.
And so this area started out,
I'll just make these numbers up cause I
don't remember the,
but they started out with like a hundred
miles of dirt roads in this mountain
system quickly expanded a 400 miles of
dirt roads because people just trying to
access wherever they want to go with an
atv really started to impact the elk to
where they,
they were getting pushed out of their
winter ranges by people on Atvs and
they're getting bullied so badly by
people that were accessing the area by
atb that they just recently closed down
something like 200 miles of roads.
And I think they're trying to even close
down even more.
But as far as I'm concerned,
it should be closed down.
Uh,
if you want to go and do,
if you want to go and ride your atv,
go ride your atv.
If your elk hunting leave the atb on the
road right by ATV.
You're talking about like those little
rangers?
Those little,
yeah,
mostly,
mostly side by sides.
There are a couple of quads but mostly
side by side.
Yeah,
those,
the,
those are very,
very controversial.
We were,
um,
in Nevada a couple of years back,
in the,
the,
the desert area,
like sage brush area near,
um,
a few hours outside of Reno.
And uh,
we experienced a few of those where
people were doing,
they were using them illegally and they
won't,
they're driving into these areas where,
you know,
you're off the road and you're,
you just,
just driving through these open plains
areas with these,
uh,
atvs and aren't supposed to be there and
spook and deer and impacting the
substrate and the soils and the bad.
Yeah,
it's on one hand I say,
well,
you know,
it's not the worst thing in the world in
terms of like if you need to get an
animal out of there,
I kind of agree with it,
but I kind of understand your point and
maybe you shouldn't even be able to do
it with that cause.
Cause then you're going to look,
I mean it's going to be really hard to
regulate whether or not a person should
or shouldn't be able to use it at any
point in time.
Yeah.
And I'm not talking about like if
somebody that's handicapped or somebody
that's truly debilitated,
wants access,
is there,
absolutely.
By all means I'm talking about able
bodied middle aged and young men are not
doing,
they're not working hard.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
right?
Like they,
they want to be able to do that.
And then there's also people that want
to be able to go in there on horseback.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's another argument.
I've heard people that have been hunting
and they,
you know,
in a quiet area and then all of a sudden
five people come by on horseback in
front of them.
You know,
that there was an outfitter and the
outfitters,
I mean they took the time to hike 19
miles deep into the back country and you
know,
it's,
it's a hard hall.
And then the next thing you know,
some people come in on horseback and
it's,
they got pack mules and all sorts of,
this shit is a fucking caravan of
animals and people and they spook and
everything out.
Yup.
And it,
it all comes down to that,
um,
that barrier of entry,
right?
Yeah.
I thrive the most,
like it's for me.
And I'm sure for you too,
it's the most rewarding to do the work
backpack in software,
right?
That's suffering.
Like I feel like we should have to
suffer for these.
Well,
it's also rewarding to do it on foot
because you're going deep into this area
that's hard to get to.
And when you do get there,
there's nothing there.
But you,
if you,
if you're the type of person that's
willing to,
to hike in seven,
eight,
nine,
10 miles,
the deeper you get,
the further you're going to distance
yourself from everybody else.
Because most people aren't going to do
that.
No.
Most people aren't going to like if you,
especially,
that's the weird thing about public
land,
right?
It's like kind of anybody can get in
there,
but who's going to get in there 22
miles?
Yeah.
Very few people.
No,
and I have people all the time,
and I'm,
I'm sure you go through this too,
but I'll kill an animal and hunters
right away,
they want to identify you.
Was that on public or private land?
What was on public land?
You know?
And,
and,
and people think that it's this and I'm
not,
I mean,
you know,
and there's certain areas of country
it's more difficult,
but people think of you killed an animal
on public land.
Like you're real hunter.
Cause you had to deal with other
hunters.
Know where I went,
there was not another person.
So you know,
it's like when,
when you're accessing,
when you're going deep and there's not
atvs,
there's not side by side and you can
actually hike into an area,
you can get away from these people,
right.
You can get away from that.
People are willing to access.
But um,
people like to celebrate public land
cause you're,
you are not a guided hunt.
You weren't in this,
well it's also a wealth both
thing too.
People want to,
they want to disparage accomplishments
for people that do things that they're,
the wealth is the barrier for entry.
Yeah.
Like,
but the problem I have with that is
first of all,
the wildest of the wild is the place
where people can't go.
You know,
and if you can get to,
and the other thing is like if somebody
said,
hey,
you know,
I'm going to give you a tag for Nevada
for some private land area that is just
an unbelievable El Con,
but it's a private land too,
but I'm gonna give it to you.
You're not going to go on.
And I've got to do that because it's
private land.
I don't do that.
No.
I say,
can I get it next year too?
Yeah.
Most people are only saying that they
wouldn't do it because they can't afford
it.
And so they want to disparage anybody
you can because there's a barrier for
entry and that barrier is financial.
But those areas,
when you go,
if you can get into these private
places,
those are the areas where they're really
wild because there's no fucking people.
You can't go back there,
you know?
And you get to see these animals
the way they would be when,
when there is no access to the public
because there isn't.
Yeah.
And that's fast.
But I get it.
I mean I get the,
the sentiment and I get why people would
be upset that some people can afford it
and others can't.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
It's definitely,
um,
yeah,
I mean it's,
it's everybody wants to participate.
I mean wants to see and access all these
different areas and,
and uh,
if you can't write and it's,
it's a negative experience of somebody
can write and I feel the same way.
Like you see,
you know,
I see this every year when I go to some
of these hunting shows around the
country.
Like I'll go to wild sheep foundation
and they bring up the Montana bighorn
tag for sale.
I would love to buy that thing.
Those,
those things are so ridiculous.
When we have those auctions in the tags
go for hundreds of thousands of dollars,
$350,000.
Fucking crazy.
That really is fucking crazy.
I mean,
the fact that people spend that money.
And then the other thing is,
I mean,
I know a guy who did that,
who hired these people to sit on this
one fucking big horn.
No.
For months they stay.
They hired these guys to basically be
fulltime employees to scout this one
gigantic big horn tracking around,
follow it,
keep an eye on it.
And then finally the season opened in.
This guy trudged in there and killed it
and killed it.
I,
here's what I would do if I was a
billionaire or had the cash,
I'd buy the tag.
I'm telling you right now to your face.
I would buy that tag often if I had that
kind of money.
But instead of hiring the crew to find
me a big Ram and waltzing in there,
an opening day and killing it,
I'd fire the crew because I have enough
money.
I'd go in there and spend the entire
season in there myself,
immersing myself into that wilderness
and using the fact that I have a pile of
cash at home to live in the wilderness
for 30 days and maybe kill a big Ram,
maybe not.
But these guys want,
they want the bragging rights.
They want that giant Ram.
They want the bragging rights.
It's,
it's,
it's a resume.
It,
it becomes a resume of animals.
And,
and I,
I kind of equate it to,
um,
I've talked about this a little bit
before,
but when,
when we were kids,
like if you went fishing with your dad
or hunting with your dad or whatever,
like let's say you went down a little
local lake here in California or
whatever,
and you guys are going bass fishing,
you guys go bass fishing and you're
catching bass or whatever.
And then all of a sudden,
one magical Sunday morning,
you or your dad hooks a monster bass and
you,
you know,
you guys grab the net and you're have
the energy and the bolt,
right,
grab that real,
you know,
keep your rod tip up.
And you know,
there's a lot of energy around this big
fish that's going to be really hard to
land.
It's such a special occurrence.
You finally get the net underneath them,
you get this big bass in the net and
you're,
you know,
you're hugging your high five and you're
all,
my God,
we've come to this like 30 times.
Just the biggest fish you've ever caught
that,
you know.
And then,
and then you take the pictures and you
go home and tell your,
you know,
you'd tell your mom,
you'd tell your friends,
you're like,
oh my God.
And he came up and he ate the frog and
we set the hook and you tell that hotel
and you have that energy that lives
around that fantastic experience.
And these guys are trying to buy that.
Like that's a remarkable experience when
you,
when you go elk hunting and you stumble
into a really big bowl or you do your
homework and you,
and you keep truncating down the
information,
you keep taking steps into the
wilderness down until you find this
really massive bowl.
You slip in,
you have the wind right,
your hidden in a Bush or against a rock
or a,
and here he comes and you can't believe
it.
You've done your homework and you've
truncated down this experience.
And here he comes in,
you'd come to full draw and he,
for whatever reason,
stopped at 30 yards and you find your
pen,
you just,
and you watch your Arrow Zip right
through them and you know you're looking
around for somebody to tell.
It's just a huge experience.
They're trying to bottle that up,
write a big fat check and try to
experience that in one afternoon that
they're trying to express
clearancing it,
experience it or is it that they want
to,
to show that they have the thing
they want to show it because that
experience I just described you,
those emotions everyone can relate to
that are people that have done this can
relate to that.
So when they show you their pictures of
their 200 inch ram,
all everybody's got,
oh man and what all,
how all my assault and really has no
knees,
no interest in that and whatsoever.
That is literally just to build a
resume.
Same with the big main lion,
right?
If you,
if you went in and it,
it is a truly wilderness experience.
You've really did your homework,
and I know I'm splitting hairs here,
but this is how my mind works.
Telling me the story.
I'd love to hear it,
but if it's anything other than that,
then it's not for [inaudible].
Well,
that's the thing about you.
What you're saying mirrors what I hear
from guys like Steve Rinella and people
that are really accomplished hunters
that are very ethical and have the right
mindset is that this is supposed to be
difficult or hard.
Yeah.
The experience is supposed to be,
you're supposed to hike all those miles.
You're supposed to go up and down those
mountains.
It's supposed to be exhausting.
It's supposed to be hard to get close to
one of these creatures.
It's supposed to be difficult.
You're supposed to not know what's over
the next ridge.
Yup.
It's suppose that's what's part of the
reward and if that reward isn't there,
it's like shooting fish in a barrel.
Shooting fish in a barrel is
weird.
It's not interesting at all.
It's great if you definitely need a
fish.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's okay.
Like there's,
there are little,
you know,
you can cut little corners in life,
right?
Like you know,
I'm not saying everything has to be like
cause cause then somebody might say,
well you're using a compound ball,
you know the guys using a recurve,
well that's a good argument if an
argument gets weird,
right?
But if you're doing it,
we say if you're doing it well and good,
it doesn't matter.
It shouldn't matter.
Like if you're an ethical,
if you're hunting for the right reasons,
you're asking yourself these big
questions.
It shouldn't matter if you pick up a
rifle and you shoot them at a hundred
yards or you pick up a recurve and you
shoot him at 10 yards.
Cause I,
I know recurve shooters,
I can only shoot like 15,
18 yards.
I know recurve shooters that can shoot
50,
60,
70 yards and um,
you know,
so we're all different.
We all liked it.
You know,
some people really
enjoy shooting the rifles.
Some people really enjoy shooting their
bill.
I don't think we should split hairs
there.
Um,
just realize that the ball hunter maybe
had to do,
go to the next level of immersion to get
himself next to an animal and,
and you know,
and the rifle hunter,
you know,
they're,
um,
you know,
there's a slightly less barrier of
entry,
but it doesn't mean that there's
anything wrong with it.
Well,
rifle,
I've heard it argue and I agree with
them,
that rifle hunting on public land is
probably more difficult than bow hunting
on private land without question.
And certainly more difficult than bow
hunting on public land because bonners
have this,
the reason I started bow hunting was
have access to public land prior to the
rifle season to extend my season to go
in the woods when it's quiet and no one
else around as sea animals acting be a
naturally,
rather than seeing this orange army and
seeing everything running for its life.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's where it gets squirrely,
right?
I mean,
public access is great,
but man,
it does get really weird and I've
experienced it when there's a lot of
hunters around.
It gets real.
Like I was in Wisconsin for opening day
a couple of years ago and it is like a
war zone.
The moment light goes off,
you hear boom,
boom,
boom.
And I was,
I was with Rinella,
we filmed it for meat eater and I looked
at my whole,
what the fuck is going on man?
Where are we at war?
He's like,
this is opening day in Wisconsin.
I was like,
that's crazy.
I mean it is just everywhere.
Just gunshots ringing out in the
distance.
Yup.
And again,
like you know sometimes we like to talk
about management.
Not every,
not every population needs to be
managed,
but literally you probably can't kill
enough deer that day in Wisconsin.
You better manage his fucking deer cause
people are hitting them with cars all
day long.
You literally couldn't kill enough and
we were eating them.
They were,
they were eating a lot of corn because a
where my friend Doug durrance farm is
where we're hunting.
It's all corn and man,
they could not have tasted better.
Yeah,
they were so good.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
it's saying we saw tatum that night and
a cast iron skillet with a garlic salt
and butter and holy shit.
Was it good?
Yeah.
We're just moaning orgasmic as to see
whether eating this deer,
it's cuisine,
man.
It's really good.
You know?
And you're sitting there with your
buddies.
Yeah,
it's,
it should be and it's valued.
Freezing cold outside your indoors and
it's warm and everybody's happy.
Man.
It was,
it was epic.
It was epic.
If something to be told.
Yeah.
It is something to be told.
I think,
and we should probably wrap this up.
We're about three hours in,
but I think I would want people,
if they've,
they've really curious about this
endeavor,
I really would want people to start with
your films cause I appreciate that.
I think that what you're doing,
if they have the time to sit down and
watch that whole thing,
what you're doing is you,
I think you represent the best.
Just the best slice.
It's so hard.
Get that slice and 22 minutes and I
think Rinella does an amazing job and
doing it in 22 minutes.
But I think what you're,
what you've done by turning these into
films and by really giving yourself the
opportunity to relay your appreciation,
the wonder and the all of nature and
you,
your immersion into that world and to do
so in such an,
an incredibly creative way and
beautifully,
visually stunning way that I think
you've done an amazing service.
And I think,
I think it's a great place for people to
start to get a look at them.
And for people that,
that do hunt,
I think they will really appreciate if
they haven't seen your stuff before.
I appreciate that man.
Like it's a,
we definitely suffer for the work,
like writing the music,
the shooting it like we do,
we want to represent ourselves with
absolute purity.
But we also realize that there are
people that have questions.
So we try to write and behave in a
manner that,
um,
like,
like you've,
like you've done today,
several times in the podcast,
you say,
Hey,
explaining what a concession is.
People don't know what a concession.
It's well,
if you can write in this certain manner,
give them some sort of an education
while you're telling them the story and
do a poetically.
And that's,
it's,
uh,
I appreciate it,
but there's so few people doing it that
way.
You know what I mean?
Sitka makes some really good films and
making some longer films.
You know,
they're in the 20 minutes and longer,
but I think very few people are doing
what you're doing,
but really making it into a movie.
You know?
I appreciate that,
man.
This next one will be about 90 minutes
in length,
and I'm really excited about it.
I can't wait,
man.
Let me know.
Donny Vinson,
ladies and gentlemen,
thanks for being on here,
man.
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
thank you.
Hm.
Okay.